اليوم الإحصائيات تقول: واحد من كل ثلاثة شخص يعاني من اضطراب نفسي
في مرحلة من حياته في السعودية
الثلث، تمام
اللي يسعون للعلاج أقل من 5% منهم
أقول لك رقم اللي أنا فخور فيه
والفخر هذا للفريق اللي وصلنا لهذه المرحلة، للمستشارين
وللعملاء اللي وثقوا فينا، قدمنا حتى اليوم 50 مليون دقيقة استشارات
الصحة الرقمية بشكل كامل 400 مليار
السعودية هنا حجم السوق أكثر من 70 مليار دولار، كصحة...
وليش تتوقع أنهم ما يبغون يستثمرون فيها؟
ما يفهمونه
أعتقد «لبّيه» لو ما خرج من المدينة لن يخرج أبدًا
يلا حيهم، حلقة اليوم تجمع ما بين موضوعين عندي اهتمام كبير فيهم
العمل والصحة النفسية
نمط حياتنا اليوم تغير بشكل كبير مقارنة بالسابق
وصرنا نتعرض لظروف وضغوطات كثيرة ومستمرة بشكل يومي
سواءًً من وظيفة وللا من عمل تجاري أو في حياتنا الشخصية
أو حتى من المحتوى اللي نشوفه في الشبكات الاجتماعية
فاليوم نستضيف باسم البلادي، مؤسس تطبيق «لبّيه»
وهو تطبيق يربط ما بين أي أحد يواجه مشكلة مرتبطة بصحته النفسية
والمختصين في هذا المجال
وما شاء الله، التطبيق مسيطر على المركز الأول في التصنيف الطبي
في متاجر التطبيقات
نتكلم في الحلقة عن المختصين وأنواعهم
وطرق استقطابهم المنصة، وتدريبهم عليها
والمشاكل اللي يواجهونها الناس معهم بسبب أن الخدمة تقدم عن بعد
بعضهم يقول: أن المختص ما يعطي الخدمة حقها
أو يقدم الخدمة تسليك ما يكون مركز مع العميل
برضو نتكلم عن العملاء وأنواعهم
مين اللي يحتاج للمنصة أساسًا؟
كيف تضمن المنصة المحافظة على خصوصياتهم؟
ونظرة العملاء لهذا النوع من الخدمات
والتحديات اللي تواجهها المنصة في ربط العميل مع المختص الصحيح
برضو بنسولف عن استحواذهم على منصة التأمل «نَفَس»
وهي شبيهة بمنصات التأمل العالمية الشهيرة
مثل: «كالم» على سبيل المثال
اللي وصل تقييمها إلى 2 مليار دولار
حلقة ثرية بالمعلومات عن مجال حساس جدًّا يمس حياتنا جميعًا
أترككم معه
حيّاك الله باسم
الله يبقيك، أهلًا وسهلًا
يا أخي، ما في شركات ناشئة كثير من المدينة طلعت، أيش السالفة؟
صادق والله
النعناع مهدّيكم؟
لا، والله يمكن حركة العمال خارج المدينة أقوى وأكبر
في المدن الرئيسية، أتكلم الرياض وجدة
بس في بمكة «سلة» مثلًا
«سلة» في، والمدينة، إن شاء الله «لبّيه»
وإن شاء الله، في كثير أحسن من «لبّيه»
وأعتقد اليوم، الحمد لله، في نمو رهيب
خصوصًا من بعد الجائحة في المدينة المنورة بدأت رغبة كبيرة
أنت بدأت في المدينة صح؟
بدأنا وما زلنا، الحمد لله، المركز الرئيسي
في المدينة؟
في المدينة المنورة نعم
نعم، السجل التجاري في المدينة
على فكرة قبل كم شهر كان أول مرة أدري أن في أنواع للنعناع
حسنًا
جديد، في «المديني» و«المغربي» الظاهر
في «الدوش»
«الدوش» و«المغربي» بس العجيب «الحبك»
«الحبك» يسمى في العالم كله حبك إلا داخل المدينة
لو تروح للمدينة تقول لهم: أبغى «حبك»
أجزم لك 90% يمكن ما يعرفونه
ليش أيش يسمونه؟
اسمه «حساوي»
تسمونه «حساوي»؟
«حساوي»
فهذه من الأشياء العجيبة
فيمكن لما نرجع للمدينة
من الأشياء الجميلة في المدينة أن أهلها ما يحبوا يخرجوا منها
وإذا خرجوا يحبوا يرجعون لها
اليوم مع الشباب اللي عندهم تميز في التقنية
بدأوا يأخذون هذه الفكرة
أن تقنية أقدر أستهدف سوق أكبر وأسواق خارجية
ولكن أكون في المدينة
خاصةً أن ممكن تشتغل مع ناس كثير عن بعد، ما يحتاج
بالضبط هذا هو
ما يحتاج
إي نعم، أن كيف نقدر نخلق شركات ابتكارية أقدر أقول
من المدينة تستهدف ناس آخرين وتوظف
أيضًا من الأفكار الجميلة اللي بدأت الآن بعض الشركات الكبيرة تعمل فيها في المدينة
شي يسمونه «النير شور»
زمان كان «الأوف شور» اللي هي شركات خارج البلد
اللي صار مشاكل وقت أزمة كورونا
أن صار في انقطاع من الدول أو صار تحديات
«الأوف شور» أيش هي بالضبط؟
«الأوف شور» تعمل شركة تابعة لك
أو موظفين يكونون خارج البلد في منطقة أخرى بسبب التكلفة مثلًا
أو أحيانًا المهارات
أو تحطوها مصر مثلًا
مثلًا مصر أو الهند أو غيرها من الدول
اليوم جاءت الفكرة الجديدة يسمونه «النير شور»
وين المناطق القريبة منك اللي تقدر أنت تتبنى فيها هذا النموذج
ويكون فيها ناس أصحاب مهارة وكفاءة عالية وتقدر...
فهذا اليوم بدأ الحمد لله، في المدينة
وأعتقد أن له مستقبل واعد، بإذن الله، وخصوصًا في المجال التقني
حلو زي...، يمكن مختلف عن الوظائف التقنية
بس زي اللي مثلًا يقول لك: أنا بسوي مركز خدمة عملاء في القصيم
بدل ما أخليه في الرياض
بالضبط
له علاقة فكرة المشروع في جو المدينة والسكينة وكذا، وللا؟
أكيد، مرة واحد كان صديق، وزي كذا
فقال: أعتقد «لبّيه» لو ما خرج من المدينة لن يخرج أبدًا
قلت له: ليش؟
قال: لأن أنتم بالسليقة وبالطبع فيكم السكينة والهدوء، وفيكم حب المساعدة
فهذا أعتقد أنه ممكن كان سبب
أن «لبّيه» شفنا أن المدينة خرج منها أعظم شيء يمر على التاريخ
فممكن «لبّيه» يكون...
بس أيش سالفة «لبّيه» ليش سويت المشروع هذا؟
والله كانت قصة شخصية الصراحة
وهي أحيانًا الحياة تكون أنت محظوظ، وترزقك في طريق معين تمشي فيه
ويُفتح لك، وأحيانًا تصفعك صفعة قوية كذا تمام
فتخليك تتوجه لشيء أنت ما تتوقعه
أنا في الأصل مهندس تخرجت من كلية الهندسة
كنت محتاج طبيب نفسي وللا؟
لا، فاللي صار أنا أسست خلينا نقول لك أول شيء
ليش أنا قريب من المجال التقني؟
وبعدين كيف جاءت قصة «لبّيه»؟
في 2012 أسست تطبيق اسمه...
كان يأتوني أصدقاء من خارج المدينة
وكنت أسوي لهم جولة في المدينة
من بدري من قبل 2012 من 2010 و2009
والحمد لله، الواحد عنده علاقات وطلعات، ويحب السفر
فكانوا يجونا للمدينة بطبيعة الحال
وتترجم لهم، وتحاول توريهم الأماكن
فكانت الأساليب الموجودة
أجانب قصدك؟
إي نعم، غير سعوديين، ويتكلمون لغة إنقليزية
لا غير، فكان الموجود ما في كنت أبحث عن مصادر ما...
وأنا أحب التراث والمدينة بشكل خاص
فأسست وقتها، قلت: خليني أعمل مبادرة
وكانت أن ليه ما نؤسس منصة متخصصة عن المدينة المنورة؟
وكانت دليل المدينة، بعدين فكرت وقتها بدأت من تطبيقات الموبايل
قلت: لا، ما أبغى خلينا نسويها تطبيق
تطبيق «دليل المدينة المنورة» فاشتغلت كثير على التطبيق
وخبرة أعتبر أنها معدومة في التقنية أو بسيطة جدًّا
مع ما في خبرة كبيرة في العمل التجاري
لكن عرضت المبادرة هذه لأكبر جهات في المدينة
مرة أعجبوا فيها لكن ما فهموها
فأنا أخذت المبادرة بنفسي قلت: أنا راح أسويها وسويتها، الحمد لله
أطلقت التطبيق، أنا يوم أطلقته كان يوم تاريخي 2012 هذا الكلام
تاريخي بالنسبة لي
أنه تطبيق من المدينة المنورة، وعن المدينة
وبدأنا وسوينا تطبيق حلو وبدأت
حتى أتذكر بعدين أقول لك جزء من أن الواحد ما عنده خبرة كبيرة في العمل التجاري
كيف أسوق له؟ بس أن، الحمد لله، بدأ يأخذ جذب
وزحمة وفي ناس تجي
وبعدها عرضته على أحد المسؤولين في المدينة المنورة، وأعجب جدًّا بالفكرة
وقعد يشوف وكذا
بعدين قلت له: طال عمرك
قال لي: والله ودي أني أستخدمه عندي
قلت: طال عمرك، بس أعطيني الجوال
ولما أعطاني الجوال، كان جوال نوكيا
نوكيا
فوالله، أنا ما أدري
قلت: والله
ما يشتغل
ما يشتغل هنا لكن أبشر احنا بنحاول...
أنا ودي ندخل على موضوع ««لبّيه»»
أنا أقول لك: فهنا أسست المشروع، وبدأنا فيه
وبعدين حتى طرق التسويق، كنت أسوّق لوحات في الشوارع
والحمد الله، وصل 500 ألف تحميل
ما شاء الله
بستة لغات، وكان رقم جيد يعتبر
لكن أنت تريد وأنا أريد، والسوق يقول لك الحقيقة
في 2015 قررت أني أوقف التطبيق
اشتغلت فيه لـ 2015 أو 2016 ممكن
نهاية 2015 أوقف التطبيق
ما كان يدخل فلوس؟
لا ما كان فلوس، الصراحة نموذج العمل كان فيه مشكلة
بعدين نزلت في تطبيقات مشابهة من جهات معينة
وفي الزبدة أنه ما نجح معي
واستهلكت فيه جهد كبير ومال، وما قدرت
وكان غير ربحي
بعدها أنا كنت أشتغل في الهندسة
وكان هذا شغلي بدوام جزئي بعدين رحت لأمريكا أدرس ماجستير
وهناك بدأت السبب الأساسي لتغيير مسار يمكن حياتي وتأسيس «لبّيه»
ليش؟
جلست هناك وبدأنا الماجستير
قدر الله أن صار لي حادث
الحادث كان مو بسيط، كان حادث دباب
أيوة، وليس حادث سيارة
فأتذكر أن حتى شالوني بالمروحية
لأن كان شوية مو عند المدينة اللي أنا كنت ساكت فيها
فأول مرة أركب مروحية
كنت تقريبًا، كنت بوعي بس أن ما أقدر أتحرك باختصار
فرحت للمستشفى، وهناك أجروا لي العملية
وبعدين طلعوني للعناية المركزة
وكان الوضع أصعب مما تتخيل
أنا دايمًا أقول: إذا اجتمعت الظلمات الثلاثة، أنا أسميها كذا
الغربة والوحدة والمرض
ويجي معهم العجز، أنك أنت عاجز شيء مو بسيط
فكان فيه...
الموضوع كان مرة، فجلست فس العناية المركزة لمدة شهر
حتى طريقة العلاج كانت معينة كذا بطريقة معينة تمت لي
ما تنام بشكل جيد إلا على..
أيش جاءك؟
تكسرت وانفكشت
واضح في كسور واجد مرة إذا شهر في العناية المركزة
وقطعت أذن
الحمد لله على السلامة
الله يسلمك
فكان الموضوع مرة صعب
فهنا أقول لك كيف الأسباب تتراكم
سبحان الله، الدكتور اللي كان يعالجني
صار بيني وبينه عراقة بعدين دخلت مرحلة التأهيل
وبعدها قررت أني أرجع للسعودية
رجعت في صيف تقريبًا 2016 للسعودية
الواقع كان يقول أني صيفية وراح أرجع
ولكني ما قدرت
تخيل أنت...، أنا تركت الوظيفة كنت بوظيفة مرة ممتازة
واستقلت منها عشان أروح أدرس
فتركت الوظيفة، خسرت وظيفتي
وبعدين كان عندي عمل تجاري فقفلته، وخسرت بعدين حتى دراستي
أحيانًا جاءني شيء أنا ما كنت أدري وقتها عنه
يسمونه اضطراب ما بعد الصدمة
اضطراب ما بعد الصدمة؟
اضطراب ما بعد الصدمة، وهذا باختصار أن أحيانًا تجيك صدمة
تخليك عاجز عن بعض الشغلات اللي حتى أنت كنت ممكن بسيطة عليك
وتحس كذا أحيانًا بقلق وأحيانًا نفسيًّا
حتى أنت يمكن ما تقدر تمارس حياتك بشكل جيد
زي أيش؟
زي أنك كنت أخاف لما أسوق سيارة مثلًا
إلى اليوم؟
لا، الحمد لله
تجاوزتها
تجاوزت المرحلة هذه
لما رجعت السعودية كان الدكتور حريص
وحقيقةً بدأت أراجع هنا في السعودية
وكان يتكلم معاي، وكنا نتواصل، الدكتور اللي في أمريكا
الحمد لله، الحياة على قد ما تعطيك صفعات
لكن أحيانًا تعطيك أشياء تحس بقيمتها لما تجيك
وكان ممكن أهمها، الأهل
مرة هذا كان فارغ معايا كثير، عودتي والأهل لما يدعمونك
حتى أخذت فترة طويلة
ما أحب أتكلم للناس أني كنت في أمريكا
والسبب، متى راجع؟ تعرف السؤال هذا؟
إي، فيضيقون صدرك
وخصوصًا لما يكون الواحد، الحمد لله، مجتهد وشاطر
فالناس دائمًا تتوقع منك النجاحات ما هم متوقعين منك الفشل
فاللي صار أني صرت أحب أتجنب الناس
بعض الأمور...، لكن اللي فرق معايا هنا أيش هو؟
لما بدأت أعمل وزي كذا، فرق معايا
اللي ولع اللمبة حقت «لبّيه» أيش؟
تواصلي مع الطبيب اللي في أمريكا
الطبيب ما كان طبيب نفسي، ولكن كان عنده مهارات في التواصل ممتاز
استمريت تتواصل معه، بس ليش؟
إيوة استمريت أتواصل معه
أحيانًا كان يبغى يشوف التحاليل، وأحيانًا كنت أبغى أطمئنه
وهو يبي يطمئن، وأقول لك: صارت علاقة أقرب ما تكون صداقة
ولكن فرق معي كثير
بس مو جزء من وظيفته؟
لا، مع وجود دعم من الأهل
هنا جاءت الفكرة، قلت: يا أخي ليش ما في دكتور سعودي؟
رجعت المدينة، وأدور ما في
وجيت، وشفت الموضوع
قلت: مو معقول، شخص على بعد 4000-5000 كيلو متر قدر يساعدني وأنا في المدينة
خليني أبدأ، حاولت يمين ويسار ما حصلت اللي كنت أبغاه
فقلت: خليني أشوف عبر الإنترنت
أتوقع أنها أبعد من 5000 كيلو متر
والله ممكن أبعد، والله ما أدري كم، لكن المسافة بعيدة جدًّا
لكن التقنية حلتها، فهنا جاءت الفكرة، قلت: خليني أبحث
بحثت عبر الإنترنت، وللا ما في حلول تحس أنها ذات جدوى
وما زالت موجودة موضوع أن أنا أروح لعيادة نفسية، لا ما أدري أيش
وصمة عار فيها
هذا سنة كم؟
هذا 2017
أذكر كان في حل، أنا ما أدري كان وقتها متوفر وللا لا
بس اللي هو «بيتر هيلب»
«بيتر هيلب»
موقع «بيتر هيلب»
كان في بداياته
وكان في موقع ثاني بعد، ناسي أيش هو؟
يمكن «توك سبيس» عالمي
إيوة «توك سبيس»
بس كانت بسيطة وضعيفة
بدأنا، وهنا جاءت الفكرة، وكانت بسيطة ومبادرة اجتماعية
أرسلت وسويت نموذج «قوقل فورمز»
قلت: أبي أسوي مبادرة للاستشارات
أساعد الناس إنهم يأخذون استشارات
واللي حاب يسجل من المختصين، الله يحييه
فسويت لك نموذج بقوقل
نموذج في «قوقل فورمز» وسويت لي حساب على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
وبدأت الناس تسجل، سبحان الله
أيش يسجلون؟
يسجل بياناته أن مستعد
مستعد يقدم استشارة؟
يقدم استشارة، نعم
وبعدها بدأنا نسوق للناس، وكانت مبادرة اجتماعية بحتة
نربط المختص مع طالب الاستشارة، مجانًا وتطوعًا
وكان حتى طريقة الخدمة لطيفة بطريقة عجيبة
ووقتها دخلت برضو في مسرعات
فكنا الزبدة نربط الناس مع بعض حساب تويتر وموقع «قوقل فورمز»
ويصير عن طريق اتصال، يتصلون على رقم
أنا طلعت رقم جوال، يتصلون على رقم الجوال، وأحول المكالمة
الهدف كان نشوف والله فيه احتياج، وللا لا؟
وبعدها، الحمد لله، بدأت تعرف موجة ريادة الأعمال في السعودية
فبدأنا، الآن دخلت في مسرعة، وغيرت معايا أشياء كثيرة
بعدين حبة حبة صار في طلب مرة واضح
صار واضح يعني شيء لا تخطئه العين
طلب كبير صار
طلب كبير، وأنا ما أقدر، وفي بعدين سويناه تطبيق
وبدأنا على الفكرة في 2017-2018
أقدر أقول أن طلع الـ«إم في بي»
النموذج الأولي
نعم، نموذج الأولي طلع، وكان بسيط جدًّا موقع إلكتروني عبارة عن صفحة دخول
وتطبيق على الجوال، تحمله
وكان فيه عدد مختصين بسيط
الهدف الأساسي، كنا نشوف هل في احتياج وللا لا؟
هل هذا الموضوع فيه يمكن قابلية؟ وهل السوق جاهز؟
البدايات ما أخفيك أول ما نزلنا التطبيق كنا ننتظر الفرج
لكن أول يوم بدون ولا عميل أصلًا
وحبة حبة حتى كانت المدفوعات، والتجربة كاملة
التجربة داخل التطبيق ما هي بأفضل طريقة، هذا 2018
و2019 نفس الشيء، وفيها اتخذت قرار
عملنا زي ما تقول إعادة تصميم التجربة بشكل كامل
نزلنا التطبيق بنسخة جديدة متكاملة، من الصفر بنيناه من جديد
نهاية 2019 اجتمعت مع الفريق، كان الفريق صغير
قلت لهم: أنا 2020 هي السنة حقتنا
هذا المشروع ديسمبر 2020 إذا لم ينجح راح نوقفه تمامًا
لازم كلنا نركز ونجتهد بحيث أننا 2020 تكون سنتنا
هذا الكلام الربع الأخير 2019
كورونا ينتظر كان
جاء يناير والأمور في تحسن، الحمد لله
فهنا جاء فبراير ومارس، وبدأت أزمة كورونا
كان توها وقتها الاجتماع ذاك خبرنا في القدر توه ما طلع
كورونا يطبخ كان عالميًا في أخبار
في المعمل ما زال ما طلع
وكان هو على قولهم: في الخلفية قاعد يجهز
المهم، وسبحان الله، أنت تريد وأنا أريد والله يفعل ما يريد
فهو يجي هنا أحيانًا تفسير الحظ، الحظ أيش يقول لك؟
الحظ: هو فرصة أتت لشخص جاهل
احنا كنا مجهزين لنا سنتين أو سنتين ونص، أو ممكن ثلاث سنوات تصدق
نشتغل ومؤمنين أن في هنا احتياج
بس بدأت الأزمة، وصار شيئين مرة فرقت معانا بشكل كبير
أول شيء أطلقنا مبادرة كان اسمها ««لبّيه» الأمل»
وتعاوننا فيها مع «المركز الوطني للصحة النفسية» مشكورين
لتقديم استشارات مجانية، المنصة مجانًا
ليش كانت عندهم مبادرة؟
بالتعاون معاهم عشان المجتمع كان فيه وقتها مرة الناس كان في غموظ
عدم يقين فيه أشياء كثيرة، وهذا سبب كثير اضطراب
الناس اليوم تداوم ولا ما بتداوم؟
وقفوه؟ لا، طيب لا إيقاف أربعة وعشرين أو اثنين وعشرين ساعة؟
الحجر، فيه قطاعات كثيرة وقفت
أتكلم قطاع الضيافة والفندقة والطيران
أنتم كلكم معاهم
وهذا زاد الطلب على موضوع الصحة النفسية؟
بالضبط، أيضًا العاملين في المجال الصحي
المجال الصحي صار عليهم ضغط مرة كبير
أهاليهم صاروا يخافون منه
أنت جاي من المستشفى، وفيها ناس مرضى كورونا
المستشفيات بعضها كاملة صارت كورونا
أنا كان أخوي طبيب وعندنا في العائلة مختصين
فالموضوع مرة صعب
حتى دائمًا كان في تحدي كبير، أهلك ما تقدر تشوفهم
فكان الموضوع صعب فأطلقنا هذه المبادرة
حقيقةً عملت لنا موجة كبيرة من الاستشارات
أيضًا كان تسريع إصدار رخص من وزارة الصحة
فأصدرنا رخصة الطب الاتصالي، وكنا من الأوائل، الحمد لله
رخصة أيش؟
الطب الاتصالي
فكانت الرخصة أول ما هي موجودة، سرّعت، الحمد لله، قدرنا نصدرها
هنا كسبنا شيئين، أول شيء...
أيش كنت تحتاج الرخصة فيه؟
إيوة، كنا نحتاجها عشان المختصيين اللي هم الأطباء المستشارين
إنك أنت تقدم الخدمة
بالضبط، بس كانوا دائمًا في تردد
المنطقة كانت رمادية
نروح للوزارة يقول لك: لا أنت ممنوع، وللا أنت مسموح
لكنه مو موجود، كان عندنا أوراق بس ما كنا شركة طبية زي اليوم
والمختص يخاف يشتغل معك
نعم بالضبطـ لأنه عمل غير...
وكنا دائمًا نقول: احنا نموذج جديد ومختلف تمامًا عن الموجود في السوق
فبالتالي أصدرنا الترخيص
فالمصدر صار أن عندنا إمكانية أن ننظم أكبر عدد من المختصيين
وصار عندنا إمكانية صرف الأدوية
والأطباء هذا جزء أساسي كبير من عملهم صرف الأدوية
فمن وقتها بدأ، الحمد لله، النمو الكبير
فساعدنا، لما تقول لي: أيش فادتنا الأزمة فيه؟
فادتنا بالشيء الأساسي إيمان اللي هم المستشارين المختصيين في الطب الاتصالي
والطب عن بعد
والسبب أن قبلها كان ما هو التدريب حقهم
حتى لو عندك ترخيص، لكن أنا ما جربته
الممارسة حقتي، بالكامل، عيادة حضورية
وليست العمل عن بعد
لما جربوا العمل عن بعد، وجربوا فوائده، وتأثيره على الناس
بدأوا يؤمنون بالموضوع، ويستقبلونه بشكل أكبر
أيضًا من ناحية العملاء، العملاء جربوا
حتى لو مو الصحة النفسية
جرب استشارة طبية عن بعد، شاف لها تأثير
حسنًا، لا والله في شيء حلو هنا
فهنا، سبحان الله، هذه الأشياء أتت لتبقى
هذه الفترة اللي غيرت فيها سرتوا إلى نموذج عمل ربحي؟
تقريبًا إي بشكل كبير أن تحولنا
لا تستحي عادي
نعم بشكل ربحي، وبدأنا نبرز أكثر في السوق
يسمونه (product market fit) أو المواءمة مع السوق
في البداية كنا احنا نحاول نحل المشكلة
بعدين هنا بدأت تتضح لنا الأمور، الحمد لله، ما انتهت 2020
يوم 27 ديسمبر كان يوم تاريخي 2020
أنا ديسمبر 19 كنت أقول للفريق: احنا راح نقفل
ديسمبر 2020 قفلنا مليون دقيقة استشارات
ما شاء الله
كنا ننتظر هذه اللحظة، لأن هذا مؤشر كبير وحققناه، الحمد لله
و،حققناها، وبدأت الأمور تتغير بشكل كبير
صار الطلب أكبر، والسمعة صارت علينا...
الموثوقية صارت أعلى، والناس...
أول كنا نتعب كثير في استقطاب المستشارين
بعدين، الحمد لله، بدأوا يجون معانا العملاء أيضًا، وعملنا حملات كثيرة
بعدها في...، الحمد لله، 2022-2021 صار النمو
اليوم، الحمد لله، أتكلم أن عندنا أكثر من 2 مليون مستخدم مسجلين في المنصة
اللهم لك الحمد، 900 مختص يساعدونا، الحمد لله
وعندنا في «مسار التنفيذ» أكثر
يعني تقريبًا نفس هذا الرقم
خلينا نبدأ بالمختصين طيب
بس دقيقة بقول لك الرقم اللي أنا فخور فيه
والفخر هذا للفريق اللي وصلنا لهذه المرحلة وللمستشارين
وللعملاء اللي وثقوا فينا
قدمنا حتى اليوم 50 مليون دقيقة استشارات، الحمد لله
هذا يعني شيء كثير لنا
وأن، إن شاء الله، أنها تكون دافع لنا لنقدم الكثير
احنا لسه ما زلنا في بداية النجاح أعتقد، ما نجحنا
ولكن أعتقد أنه مؤشر يدل على أن في احتياج
وأن «لبّيه» بإذن الله، قادر يساعد الناس
وقادر أنه يحقق الرسالة اللي احنا من أجلها بدأنا
معك في رحلة أمل، ومنها رحلة
وأن الأمل هو وقوده، واحنا موجودين لتحقيقها
مذاكر، ما شاء الله، عليك
خلنا نأخذها جزء جزء
عندك الجزء الأول جزء المختصين
نعم صحيح
المختصين أول شيء أيش نوعه؟
كشخصيًّا أنا استخدمتها الخدمة
ممتاز
لا مو ممتاز، تقول: الحمد لله على السلامة
فاستخدمت «لبّيه»
فيه أنواع مختصين
أعرف الأنواع بس دائمًا أتلخبط وأنساهم
وفي تفاصيل ثانية بندخل فيها بعد شوي
بس خلنا نتكلم الحين عن الأنواع، في نوعين الآن من المختصين صح؟
نعم، هو بشكل مبسط فيه عندك الطبيب النفسي
وعندك الأخصائي أو المعالج النفسي
الطبيب النفسي هو اللي تخرج من كلية الطب
وهو طبي في الأصل، بعدين أخذ الزمالة أو البورد السعودي في الطب النفسي
فيتخصص بعدين في الطب النفسي
وبعدها ممكن يتخصص تخصص دقيق مثلًا الإدمان أو الفصام
بس هذا الطبيب النفسي يكون معالجته بشكل أساسي الأدوية؟
نعم صحيح، التشخيص مرة مهم
أنه هو اللي عنده القدرة الأساسية على تشخيص الحالة في البداية
وبعدين يُصرف الأدوية، ومتابعتها بشكل عام
ما يعالج إلا بالأدوية؟
في الغالب نعم، بس بعضهم عنده مهارات اللي هو الأخصائي النفسي
أخذ كورسات الأخصائي النفسي وبعض طرق العلاج
زي العلاج السلوكي المعرفي أو شيء من هذا القبيل
فيكون عنده المهارتين
بس الأساس هو التشخيص وصرف الأدوية
فهذا الطبيب النفسي، وبعدين في المعالج النفسي
المعالج باختصار أو الأخصائي النفسي
هو الظاهر اسمه معالج سلوكي
نعم، وفي الإنقليزي عالم نفسي، وهو يكون خريج كلية علم النفس
ما درس طب؟
لا ما درس طب، هو درس علم النفس
وبعد ذلك بدأ الممارسة الطبية تدريب بعدين يأخذ الرخصة، ويبدأ
وبعدها يأخذ ماجستير مثلًا في علم النفس، وهنا يتنوعون
في لها أكثر من تخصص مثلًا إرشادي أو عيادي أو غيره
ولكن في الغالب هو هذا الشخص ليس بطبيب
لا يستطيع صرف أدوية، ولكنه يساعدك سلوكيًّا
ويساعدك في أن أنت تفهم نفسك بشكل أكبر
يساعدك في ترتيب أفكارك وتوضيحها عن طريق طرق علاجية معتمدة
يشوف الأمور من زوايا مختلفة
نعم، أنا أقدر أشبهها لك عشان مرة تتضح الصورة
أكثر الناس تفهم كرة القدم، لكن لما يجيه لاعب إصابة
مثلًا إصابة الرباط الصليبي: هي إصابة معروفة ومشهورة
ومن أقوى الإصابات
إصابة رباط الصليبي تحتاج نوعين من العلاج، ولا واحد فيهم يكفي
هي عكّازين
أول شيء العملية، أنت لازم تسوي عملية في الركبة
لمعالجة الحدث اللي صار لك، بعدها التأهيل
حلو
لازم تأخذ مرحلة تأهيل مع أشخاص متخصصين فيه
بحيث أن جسمك يرجع بكامل قوته، أنك تمارس الرياضة ممتاز
أيش علاقته بالـ...؟
إيوة، هنا أيش علاقته؟ الطبيب هو الأول هو زي اللي سوى العملية
هو صلح الكسر
نعم، هو التدخل المباشر اللي يعطيك مثلًا الدواء
اللي يشخصك، أنت معاك مثلًا حالتك اكتئاب معينة
وهذا الدواء تأخذ عليه ثلاثة أو ستة شهور كورس مكتمل
لكن هل يكفي الدواء؟
لا
لا، أحيانًا نعم بس في الغالب لا
تحتاج علاج سلوكي معرفي أو زيارة معالج نفسي
يحيث يدخل معاك في برنامج
يساعدك على فهم نفسك وسلوكياتك والناس اللي حولك
وعلى ترتيب أفكارك
بالتالي هي عكازتين أنت تمشي عليهما
الدواء مهم والعلاج السلوكي المعرفي
أو المعالج النفسي وعمله مهم جدًّا، هي عكازين
أنا لو رحت فقط معالج نفسي، هل يكفي؟
قد يكفي لأن أحيانًا أنت تروح للعلاج الطبيعي ممكن يكفي
أنا ما أحب الأدوية
قد يكفي، ولكن مهمة الاثنين فتقريبًا هذا أقرب مثال الناس تفهمه
يوضح لك التكامل في العملية العلاجية بين الطرفين
هذا رأيي الشخصي غير طبي، وللا هو بنصيحة
بس شخصيًّا أشوف إذا كان اللي فيك ما هو اضطراب يعني شيء عضوي
المفروض ما تروح للطبيب النفسي
جرب تصلح نفسك أولًا، هل هذا الشيء صحيح وللا...؟ أحس
هذه وجهة نظرك
يا أخي ليش أعلق نفسي بأدوية
نعم، شوف هي الصراحة ما يحتاج أن الواحد يخاف منه
حتى الأدوية النفسية، اليوم في كثيرين...
لو أن فيها خطر لم تصرح صح وللا لا؟
الناس الموجودين في وزارة الصحة وهيئة الغذاء والدواء
المختصين في هذا المجال أحرص مننا وأكثر علمًا
وهذه كلها علوم تجريبية تطبيقية
إي، لا هو النقطة أنك ما تأخذ شيء ما تحتاجه مو أنه سيء
الاحتياج يختلف من شخص لآخر
خلنا عشان ما نطلع من نقطة المختصين
أنا اللي راح أقوله: أن أنا ماني طبيب، ممكن أطباء يجاوبون عليه أكثر
ولكن هي أساليب علمية معتمدة تم تجربتها على الملايين
والحمد لله، ناجحة
وكلها مهمة، أنا ما أقدر أقول لك: هذا مهم وهذا مو مهم
أكيد
كلها، واللي يحدد المختص
بس شلون الآن في وضعك اليوم
شلون تتأكد المختص اللي بجي عندك، أول شيء مؤهلاته جيدة؟
صحيح
أخذ تدريب جيد، ويقدر يستخدم التقنية بشكل جيد
وهذه بركز عليها بعد شوي كثير، بس خلنا على الثلاث نقاط هذه
شلون تتأكد أن هذا مناسب لـ«لبّيه»؟
هذا الموضوع مرة مهم
احنا زي ما قلت لك: احنا منصة طبية معتمدة من وزارة الصحة
فعندنا العلاج المبني على الأدلة
أيش...؟
يعني معتمدة على التأصيل العلمي وليس على...
علاج معتمد على التأصيل...
التأصيل العلمي ومجرب ومعتمد
وليس شيء مثلًا غير علمي أو شيء كذا بالهواء لا
سواليف
سواليف باختصار، لكن هذا مو موجود عندنا
فبالتالي أنت تحتاج أن تتأكد
عندنا ثلاث مراحل، أول شيء احنا عندنا فريق طبي داخلي
الفريق الطبي هذا مسؤول عن تحديد أهلية المختص
هل هو ينفع مع «لبّيه» أو لا؟
أول شيء نتأكد من الأوراق
فبالتالي أنت عشان تعمل في الممارسة الصحية في السعودية
يكون عندك ترخيص في هيئة التخصصات الصحية
فهل هذا الشخص مرخص أو لا؟
هل شهاداته...؟ أصلًا لو ما عنده شهادات ما يأخذ الترخيص باختصار
لكن احنا نتأكد منه عشان نعرف من وين متخرج؟ وسنوات الخبرة
مصيبة تجيب دكتور متعلم من اليوتيوب
نعم، هذه المشكلة الكبيرة
فنعرف سنوات الخبرة، ومن وين تخرج ومؤهلاته العلمية؟
هل أخذ دراسات عليا؟ هل أخذ دبلومات معينة؟
شهادات مكثفة في مجال معين، زائد الترخيص
بعدها نجي للمرحلة الثانية عندنا اختبار كتابي، يُرسل له ويجاوب عليه
وكلها حالات وغيرها من الأمور
نتأكد من طريقته في التعاطي مع الأمور وجديته وحرصه
بعدها ينتقل للمرحلة الثالثة اللي هي المقابلة الشخصية
المقابلة يكون فيها ثلاثة أشخاص
اثنين مختصين وواحد من عندنا من الفريق الإداري
بحيث أننا نتأكد أن والله...، وتكون بالفيديو
ونشوف كيف قدرته وإمكانيته على تقديم الخدمة
وعندنا مشترطين سنوات خبرة معينة، وغيرها من الأمور
فبعدين تمت الموافقة، وسنوات الخبرة حقته متلائمة مع «لبّيه»
وعنده المؤهلات الكافية، ومرخص
تجاوز المقابلة الشخصية، وتجاوز الاختبار الكتابي
حياك الله في «لبّيه»
وندخل في مرحلة التأهيل
أو تدريبه على استخدام المنصة
تدريب استخدام المنصة عندنا لوائح متكاملة
لازم يوقع عليها، ويقرأها بشكل كامل
وعندنا أدلة وإجراءات، الحمد لله
اشتغلنا عليها وطورناها بشكل مرة كبير
في تفاصيل التفاصيل، وعندنا فيديوهات متكاملة
وعندنا تدريب مباشر معهم بحيث أنه يتدرب على تقديم الخدمة
ونجرب معه استشارة لازم يسوي تجربة للتطبيق
بعدها يدخل، ويقدم الاستشارات
فأنتم تعتمدين على الناس اللي يجونكم، وللا برضو تروحون تكلمون...؟
كلا الطريقتين، في البدايات كنا كثير احنا نروح
الآن، الحمد لله، «لبيه» صار اسمه معروف عند المختصين
فبالتالي في الغالب هم يروحون
إلا بعض المختصين اللي مثلًا عندنا تخصص معين فيه عدد قليل
أو في ناس معينة بالأسماء فنروح نستقطبهم بشكل مباشر
هم اللي يحطون السعر؟
لا، عندنا تسعيرة متكاملة
بناءً على أيش؟
بناءً على التصنيفات من هيئة التخصصات الصحية
خليني أخد معك الأطباء
مثلًا الأطباء في السعودية أربعة تصنيفات
في طبيب نائب وطبيب نائب أول وطبيب استشاري
وطبيب استشاري، تخصص دقيق
هذه كل وحدة لها تعريف
احنا بناءً عليها نحدد التسعيرة، وبناءً على عدد سنوات الخبرة
يكون لك سعر أعلى
فبالتالي أخذنا العرف الموجود عشان ما ندخل في تشعبات
لأن أنت لما تأخذ الرخصة
يقول لك: طبيب استشاري، في الترخيص حقك من هيئة التخصصات
فبالتالي له سعر
وهذا شيء يسوونه السوق وللا أنتم اخترعتوه؟
إيوة ولا، بعضهم نعم وبعضهم لا
بعضهم سعر معين، وبعضهم يقول لك: هذا قديم معنا سعره عالي
وهذا توه جديد
لكن احنا حرصنا أن نأخذ على التصنيف المهني للـ...
وتكون بالساعة تحسب له إياه؟
نعم بالساعة
وكم يأخذ منها الدكتور؟
الدكتور كنسبة يأخذ 70% بالمتوسط
كمتوسط 70%
أيش اللي يزيدها وينقصها؟
على حسب عدد الاستشارات مثلًا، هو العامل الأساسي
كلما زادت؛ كلما زادت النسبة؟
نعم
ليش؟ تبي تحفزه أنه يعطي؟
كمحفز إيوة، وما على المحسنين من سبيل
المحسن دائمًا تقول له: أحسنت، وتكافؤه بالطريقة اللي تقدر عليها، هذا جزء
هو أساس أنه...
أنا أشوف التحدي أنا ليش كنت بركز على النقطة حقت التقنية
التحدي بشكل كبير في كيف تضمن أن الدكتور
اللي غالبًا عنده وظيفة
هو أكيد أنه يستخدم «لبّيه» يقدم الاستشارات كشيء جانب بحياته مو كشيء أساسي
ما راح يتفرغ له، عندكم مختصين متفرغين وللا؟
نعم
خل نقول الأصل
ما هو براتب، مو موظف بدوام كامل عندنا
ولكن «لبّيه» هو الشيء الأساسي عنده
خلنا نقول: الأصل أن يكون عنده وظيفة
صحيح
ويستخدم التقنية لتقديم اللي هو المفترض أن يكون بعد دوامه
فأنا واجهت إشكالية في الموضوع هذا مع أحد الأطباء
حتى فريق العمل بالمناسبة لقينا ناس يستخدموا «لبّيه»
أنا شوف في نوعين من الناس
يا ناس يمدحون «لبّيه» مرة، ومبسوطين من الطبيب وأمورهم تمام
يا ناس على الأقل الآن أو اللي حولي الدكتور يسلك لهم
واحد مثلًا أثناء من فريق العمل يقول: يكلمني وهو بسيارة
واحد ثاني يقول: الدكتورة تكلمني وأولادها جنبها، وتزعّق عليهم
فكيف تضمن أن الدكاترة هؤلاء يستخدمون التقنية
بالطريقة اللي المفروض يستخدمونها فيها
ما هو قاد متكي في البيت بعد الدوام
وفاتح الجوال اللي إي أيش مشكلتك؟ يا ولد بس
فأيش تسوي عشان تقدر تطلع الدكاترة هؤلاء؟
بالضبط، أنا أعتقد أن هذه أحد تحديات الطب الاتصالي عن بعد
وهي أقدر أقول أن الأمثلة اللي أنت قلتها ممارسات مرفوضة عندنا في «لبيه»
حتى في لوائحنا مرفوضة تمامًا
ولكن هي تحدث في الأخير
تحدث أن مقدم الخدمة الطرف الآخر اللي هو المختص ما كان غالبًا...
هي جزئين يا أن البيئة اللي حوله ما تساعده أن يقدم الخدمة
أو اللي أنت قلته: أن أحيانًا ما يعطيك الحل اللي أنت تبغاه صح
أو أن زي ما قلت تسلك
المشكلة كلمة تسلك هذه تعريفها كبير ما نقدر نحددها
لا، اللي كلمته أنا مثلًا كنت أقول له على مشكلة
أنا أشوف أنا أيش أتصور أو أتوقع من المعالج السلوكي
نعم
تجي تقول له مشكلة معينة، وهو يساعدك تفكفكها، وتفهمها أكثر وتستوعبها
بعدين يقول لك: مثلًا خلنا نجرب نسوي كذا
أحيانًا يعطونك زي تدريبات تشتغل عليها
بحيث أن إما يساعدك تغير نظرتك للموضوع هذا
عندي خبرة للأسف سابقًا في الموضوع
هذا قاعد يقول لي: احمد ربك، كأني قاعد أشكي لخويي في الاستراحة حرفيًّا
الحمد لله، يا رجال أنت بخير وعافية
إي، الحمد لله، أنا في ألف خير وعافية
أنا ماني قاعد أجحد الموضوع هذا، بس ساعدني واشتغل معي شوي
والله صحيح صادق، هو في الأصل أنه...
عمومًا أنا ماني مختص لا أخصائي نفسي ولا طبيب
ولكن أنا أقول لك: في الأصل أن ما يصير هذا الشيء
بس كصاحب منصة كيف تتأكد؟
هنا السؤال الأساسي، كيف نتأكد؟
أنا بعد ما نسوي مرحلة القبول والتأهيل
نحاول نتأكد أن ما يدخل في المنصة إلا الممتاز
معناه أن عندنا فحص الجودة مختلف، أولها التقييم
نماذج إذا أنت قيمت المختص هذا بعدها أو لا؟
إذا في تقييم واحد أقل من خمسة
شعرنا أن العميل، أولًا في تدخل مباشر
لو العميل رفع شكوى أول شيء على طول الرصيد يرجع له
ويقدر يأخذ استشارة مجانية أو أحيانًا زي ما صار في حالتك
ما كان المختص المناسب لك أو ما فهم الحالة بشكل جيد
نحولك على أحد آخر ممتاز
بدون ما أدفع مرة ثانية؟
بدون ما تدفع، النقطة الثانية المهمة بالنسبة لنا
أن نرسل مختص ونستفسر منه
احنا عندنا نظامين، في تقييم بعد الحالة مرة سريع
اللي خمسة نجوم وتكتب رسالة
والثاني أنك لا تقييم طويل، وهذا يفيدنا كثير في فحص الجودة
ونتأكد أن أحيانًا في بعض المهارات يكون مثلًا ممتاز
بس في مهارة معينة ما هو قوي، فنسعى معه أن نحسنها
أيضًا عندنا الشكاوي، إذا رفع شكوى
على طول يرفع تذكرة
ونتحقق من المستشار، ونتواصل مع العميل، نفهمه بشكل أفضل
وبعدين عندنا إجراءات مختلفة
وعلى حسب نوع الشكوى، وعلى حسب تكرارها
تبدأ من إنذار بسيط، إنذار للمستشار، وإنذار ثاني، وإنذار ثالث
وبعدين يقع في التعاون بشكل كامل
طلعتوا واجد من المنصة؟
نعم، مو واجد، لكن طلعنا عدد لا بأس فيه
والسبب أحيانًا مو مشكلة مهنية في التخصص
يعني ما هو مهنيًّا عنده مشكلة لا
لكن عنده عدم احترافية مثلًا يتغيب عن الحضور للحالات
هذه من أكبر المشاكل عندنا إذا أنت غبت
لازم تسوي تأجيل المفروض قبل الموعد
أو زي ما الوضع الحالي حوله العملاء يشتكون منه مثلًا
أو أن...، في مشاكل كثيرة
المشكلة التقنية تتأزم أكثر كذا
لا، أنا أتكلم لك كيف أنت تضمن أن تقدم...
أن المهنية في الموضوع هذا مرة مهمة
وبالتالي نحرص أن نقدمها بشكل جيد
لا، للأمانة بس عشان...
خليني أقول لك الجانب الإيجابي
قبلما ننتقل من الجانب السلبي أنا بس بقول إحقاقًا للحق
المشكلة هي فعلًا في الطب الاتصالي بشكل عام
أني أذكر ذكرت الحين موقف صار لي مع «بيتر هيلب» المنصة العالمية
منصة عالمية
نفس الشيء معالج سلوكي، كان في موضوع برضو أحتاج استشارة فيه
وكانت الاستشارة فيديو
فالرجال فتح الكاميرا تفاجأت أنه واحد جالس ومتكي
تيشيرت وعليه رسومات
ولابس سماعات كذا كبيرة حقت الظاهر اللعيبة ولا شيء
فبعدين قعدت أناظر فيه اللي، هذا دكتور؟
يعني هل أسولف معه؟
أحسه واحد كذا، ما أدري أحسه كأنه مراهق شكله
ما أحس أنه واحد احترافي، فكانت الجلسة غريبة
صح
ولا ضبطت الأمور، وطلبت تغييره
فأحس عدم الجدية هذه عالميًّا
صحيح، والآن احنا نحاول نحسنها ونطورها
بطريقتين نضع محفزات أكبر للمتهيّئين
للي يعطي وقت أكبر للعميل، واللي يكون في مكان ممتاز
واللي يقدمها بشكل أفضل، والعكس للي لا ما يكون جاهز
إلى ذاك الوقت العميل اللي بيستخدم «لبّيه» هذه كنصيحة
يروح يشوف التقييمات السيئة حقت الدكتور
إذا مكتوب أنه لا يحضر وللا يسلّك، وللا أيًّا كان اسحب عليه
أهم شيء أنك تهتم في نفسك
قاعد أساعدكم
اهتم في نفسك
خلينا نأخذ الجانب الإيجابي
شلون احنا عندنا اليوم، الحمد لله
أعتقد أن احنا من أعظم المنصات في المجال الطبي بشكل عام
بعدد التقييمات
احنا قربنا نوصل 350 ألف تقييم في التطبيق، عملاء كتبوا تقييمات
أنتم، ما شاء الله، أشوفكم في...
نسبة الرضا في التقييمات أكثر من...
في متجر التطبيقات أنتم الأعلى في التصنيف الصحي
نعم، احنا اليوم قربنا نكمل سنتين ما نزلنا عن الأول
العام الماضي، الحمد لله
مع «توكلنا» و«صحتي»
احنا كنا من أعلى التطبيقات تحميلًا
التطبيقات الطبية «توكلنا» و«صحتي» و«تباعد»
وواحدة من الشركات الكبيرة المدرجة بعدين «لبيه»
الحمد لله، هذا أتكلم...
فبالتالي طبيعة الحال مع الضغط الكبير على الخدمة مع الطلب
تصير التحديات والمشاكل، ودورنا احنا أن نضمن ونحسن
الآن نشغل على أشياء مرة ممتازة
في تحسين أن تصل للمختص المناسب
وتوعيتك بالجلسة، وأخذك للجلسة بشكل جيد
فنحاول نحل التحديات هذه
حلوة
فأنا أتكلم بس نقطتي الأساسية أن صحيح
اليوم وبكرة وبعد سنة وبعد عشر سنوات
راح يجون ناس مو راضين عن الخدمة، هذه حقيقة لازم نؤمن فيها
ولكن، الحمد لله، أولاً اللي راضين أكثر، هذه النقطة الأولى
ثاني شيء احنا في مرحلة تحسين وتطوير
أنا أقول لك احنا لسه ما زلنا في البداية
المجال كله ما زال في البداية
هذه كلها تجارب احنا نتعلم منها المشاكل والتقييمات وغيرها التحديات الموجودة
نجلس مع المختصين بشكل شهري، ونسمع منه، ونحاول نطور
نسمع للعملاء واستبيانات بشكل مختلف، نسوي عميل سري
هل فيه مشكلة في مثلًا التدريب أو التعليم حق المختصين بشكل أساسي
اللي ممكن يؤدي للموضوع هذا؟
والله هو موضوع حساس، ويحتاج مبادر وطنية
لكن خلني أكلمك عنه، احنا الحمد لله، من ناحية الأطباء
في الغالب لا يوجد مشاكل
والسبب: جودة في التعليم والتأهيل والتدريب
فبالتالي، الطبيب السعودي
بعيدًا عن جانب التقنية بس بعرف...
من أكفأ الأطباء
لكن من ناحية المعالجين النفسيين هم حجرة أساسية
ومن أكثر الناس المهمين، أنا أشوف اليوم دورهم في المجتمع
والله لا يقل أهمية عن أي شيء آخر
والسبب أن ربي أكرمهم بهذه المهنة والمهارات
اللي تساعد في تغيير حياة الإنسان
ولكن الواقع يقول: أنهم حقيقة يعانون من الناحية التعليمية
ويعانون من ناحية التدريب
اليوم الجامعات حقيقةً، المناهج ما هي متوائمة مع السوق
اليوم الخريجين يعانون
المناهج القديمة قصدك؟
قديمة بصراحة. مو كل الجامعات ولكن يوجد هذا الشيء
التدريب ما زال أقل من المطلوب
الشهادات التخصصية، اليوم لما نتكلم مثلًا في مجال الأعمال والهندسة وغيره
دائمًا في شهادات تخصصية «بي إم بي» وغيرها
والناس تحرص عليها
في المجال النفسي موجودة، لكن التدريب عليها مرة ضعيف
هذا بس للمعالج السلوكي قصدك؟
أنا أتكلم عن المعالجين، هنا التحدي مع المعالجين
الأطباء أمورهم طيبة
الأطباء أمورهم طيبة بس مشكلتهم أنه قليل، وغير متاحين
المعالجين موجودين أكثر، ولكن التدريب والتأهيل
أنت كغير مختص كيف تعرف؟ هل هم قالوا لك كذا؟
نعم، هم قالوا لي، واحنا شايفين السوق
اليوم، الحمد لله، خمس أو ست سنوات في السوق يا مشهور، واضحة
فهم يشتكون من عدم وجود تدريب
نعم، لا يوجد يا شيخ، والتدريب بسيط
تروح تأخد الرخصة بشكل معياري موجود عالميًا في الدول الأخرى
ما نحتاج اختراع العجلة، موجودة البرامج المهنية
وموجود طريقة للترخيص، وطريقة للممارسة العلاجية
نتمنى أنها تتطبق وتحسن المجال، وكفاءته تزيد
يعني اللي بحسن نفسه من المعالجين السلوكيين النفسيين لازم يطلع برى؟
لا ارفع المعايير
كثيرين يروحون برّى علشان يأخذون دورات
ويأخذون درسات عالية حتى يتحسن مستواهم
وتصير كفاءتهم عالية، والعائد ترى موجود
أنت المكافئة وأنك إذا اجتهدت على نفسك هذا المجال، راح تحصل
صدقًا بالمجال صار فيه اليوم طلب زائد
والناس بدأت تصير وعيها أعلى في المجال
حتى المنصة يحصل واجد ممكن؟
نعم، الحمد لله
كم يدخلون تقريبًا؟
والله خلينا نأخدها كمتوسط
كمتوسط
متوسط 7000 ريال
في الشهر؟
نعم
هذا يأخذها كشيء جانبي
بس كم لو بنأخذها الناس اللي يسمونهم كبار الإصلاحيين
اللي هم داعسين في المنصة؟
أعلى بكثير
عشرات الآلاف؟
إي عشرات اللآلاف وأعلى
أنت تقول: مئات اللآلاف
لا مئات الآلاف
يطلعون عشرات الآلاف شهريًّا إذا هم ملتزمين، ويقدموا خدمة بشكل جيد
بالضبط، احنا في «لبّيه» اللهم لك الحمد
مع التوعية اللي صايرة في المجتمع
جزء من عملنا من أول يوم إعادة تعريف عمل المختص النفسي
جزء من التحدي عدم إيمان الناس للعلاج، هذا جزء أساسي
ممتاز، خلنا ندخل هنا على موضوع العملاء دامك جبت طاري الناس
نبدأ أول شيء مين العميل المستهدف لـ«لبيه»؟
غالبًا في هذا الموضوع حتى في العيادات وبرة
واحد مريض نفسي يروح للعيادات، فأنتم من بالضبط تستهدفون؟
احنا العميل الحقيقي اللي يعاني...
أتكلم على اللي ممكن الآن يحتاج «لبيه» هذه اللحظة
اللي عنده تحدي نفسي نقطة وآخر السطر
أيًّا كان التحدي؟
إي، باختصار اللي مثلًا عنده أخذ له فترة تتجاوز من أسبوعين إلى شهر
عنده مثلًا اضطراب في النوم
ما يقدر ينام أو ينام مرة وقت كثير، أو عنده اضطراب مع الأكل
حالته المزاجية منخفضة أو مرة مهيبر بشكل كبير
فعلاقته مع الآخرين إما أنه منعزل مرة بشكل كبير
مرحلة حزن مستمر الفترة طويلة
فبالتالي هو شخص يعاني من تحدي نفسي
ويعتقد أنه مو قادر يتعامل مع الوضع زي ما كان قبل كذا
ويحس أن في تغيرات تصير معاه هو شخصيًّا
والغريب، أعتقد وما أدري تأكد كلامي إذا صحيح
أن فيه كثير من الناس إذا ما كانوا الأغلبية ما يدرون إذا عندهم مشكلة نفسية
صحيح
يعتقدون مثلًا زي كذا إذا ما كان ينام، عادي أكيد أنها أزمة وتعدي
حتى إذا بقول لأحد أني أروح للطبيب النفسي، يعتقدون أني...
أن فيك مشكلة
أنه مضروب مرة
يقلل من المروءة
بالضبط، أنه شيء غريب أن ليش تروح أمورك طيبة؟
إي، أموري طيبة بس في نقطة
هي مراحل، أول مرحلة أنا أعتقد فيها أن عدم الوعي بما هو الاضطراب النفسي
وهذا موجود بشكل كبير
وفيه كثيرين أصلًا ما يدرون أن هذا مرض مصنف
ولا يدرون أن هذه الاضطرابات هي مصنفة أمراض
اليوم الاكتئاب الدراسات تقول: أن 2025 راح يكون الاضطراب الأول
عالميًّا
ومسبّب للوفاة
وهو أكثر اضطراب انتشارًا في العالم، هذا الاكتئاب
خصوصّا بعد أزمة كورونا
وخليني أقول لك المرحلة الثانية
المرحلة الثانية: حتى لو قال: حسنًا في مرض
بس ما يعرف طريقة العلاج أو كيف يتعالج؟ ما يدري
وبعدين عرف أن فيه مرض
أن في شيء اسمه مرض اكتئاب وفي مرض اسمه قلق
وعرف أن في طرق علاجية بس يخاف أن يتخذ هذه الخطوة
بسبب وصمه عار، وأنه يخاف مثلًا...
نظرة الناس
نظرة الناس وغيرها، أيش يقولون عني، أو لا، أنا مع الوقت راح أتحسن ما أحتاج
يمكن هذا الجانب ما يُغطّى في البرنامج عادةً
بس كثير من أصحاب الشركات اللي أعرفهم
عندهم كمية اضطرابات
وما أقولها عيبًا فيهم بس بحكم ضغط العمل ومشاكلهم
والضغوطات، والأمور هذه كلها
تجيهم نوبة هلع أو اكتئاب أو احتراق، يجيهم أشياء كثيرة
وللأسف كثير منهم ما يبغى يتعامل معها
يبغى خلاص يخليها تدري أنا...
ويبدأ يأخذ حبوب، وأحيانًا يصرف لنفسه
أو يتعامل مع دكتور يصرف له الشيء اللي يبغى يأخذه، فمشكلة كبيرة
أعتقد أن أنا وأنت لأن يمكن قريبين مجال رواد الأعمال وشاهدناه
وأنا أعطيك إياها من ناحية علمية، ومن ناحية أبحاث ومصادر
قالوا عملوا دراسة في أمريكا عن رواد الأعمال وعلاقتهم بالأمراض النفسية
50% يعانون من القلق
من القلق؟
إي 50% من رواد الأعمال و30% يعانون من الاكتئاب
المفجع في الموضوع نتكلم، عن أمريكا
أن 15% منهم عندهم إدمان
إدمان؟
إدمان، وهذه هي المشكلة، وهذا التحدي الكبير
والسبب اللي أنت قلته، الضغوطات والتعامل معها
أحيانًا أنت كرائد عمال، كلنا في منطقة الراحة
بعدين يقول لك: انتقل...
منطقة الراحة
اخرج من منطقة الراحة لكن أنت تخرج منها، تجي تحت الشمس
الشمس...، العالم والواقع يحرقك، الناس ما تحب الفشل
تنجلد جلد من أهلك واللي حولك
أنت نفسيًّا لن تكون راضي عن نفسك، فتلقاك تضغط على نفسك
وهو جزء من النجاح، سبحان الله
النجاح يجي مع الجهد والمصابرة والاجتهاد
فبالتالي دائمًا شخصيًّا أقول: لا معنى للنجاح وللثروة إذا وصلت لها إذا خسرت نفسك
إذا خسرت نفسك ثم ماذا؟
فتصير أنت متمحور حول العمل، متعتك كلها في العمل
وبعدين يجي مثلما قلت أنت: الاضطرابات أو الاحتراق الوظيفي
أو أحيانًا أنك أنت ما تنجح، وما تقدر تتجاوز المرحلة
بالتالي هي هنا من أكبر الصعوبات
الاحتراق تحديدًا من أسوأ الأشياء اللي مريت فيها في حياتي
لأنك ما تدري أيش فيك؟
أنك فجأة كذا تحوم كبدك من الشغل، تكره شغلك، وما تبغى تسويه نهائيًّا
وتحس بأنه شيء منطقي
بعدين إذا اتخذت قرارات وأخذت استراحة وتعافيت
تكتشف أنه ما كنت في عقلك فعليًّا
نعم، صحيح هو تفقد المعنى، أنت في الأخير تلقاك مكرس
تقول رسالتك في الحياة هذا الشيء
تمام خصوصًا احنا الشباب هذا الشيء عندنا مرة تحس أن عندك حماس للموضوع
وهذا هو الصح، أنت لا تكون مؤمن وواثق من مشروعك وحماستك
لكن أحيانًا هي شعرة مرة فاصلة
تصير أنت كل شيء العمل حقك، وأنا قد جاتي نفس اللي جاتك
تحس أنك فجأة...
فصلت خلاص ما تقدر...
الأمور كلها خرجت من السيطرة
ودك تهرب بس
هنا تجي تدري أيش؟
لو احنا نلاحظ الديون اللي تجي عند أصحاب المشاريع
مو بس رواد الأعمال حتى التجار
حتى أي واحد يجي يتعامل مع التجارة
اللي يدخلون في مرحلة الديون، أيش سببها؟ قرارات خاطئة
أيش سبب القرارات الخاطئة؟
عدم تحليل الموضوع بشكل جيد، وأنا شخصيًّا، هذا رأيي الشخصي
جزء أساسي أنه ما كان نفسيًّا مهيئ أن يأخذ القرار، مضغوط
صح
فخلاص ويلا، هو ما هو دارس الموضوع
حتى بس تجي تقول له: أنت ليه سويت زي كذا؟
يقول: والله
يا ابن الحلال
سويتها صح، فيأخذ المخاطرة، وما هي محسوبة بطريقة كاملة
فيجيب العيد، قرارت خاطئة
بعدين يخسر العمل التجاري واللي حوله
ويخسر أشياء كثيرة هو كان يقدر يأخذ خطوة للوراء
ويحلل الموضوع بشكل جيد، وفي ناس مختصين يقدرون يساعدون
يأخذوا معهم ساعة، ويسمع منهم، وبعدها ينطلق
إي، بس مشكلة الخطوة هذه أصعب شيء
الخطوة هذه تحدي كبير
مسألة أني أقرر أروح وأحلل، وأشوف أيش المشكلة اللي فينا
أو هذه مشكلة ثانية بجيك فيها
بس أيش أيش أبرز المشاكل اللي تجيكم في المنصة؟
والله القلق، واضطراباته كثيرة
هو الأعلى؟
إي
أيش هو القلق؟
القلق هو أحد اضطرابات المزاج مثلًا...
يصير كل يوم، وطول الوقت
الرهاب يجوز تحت القلق أن الحالة المزاجية وغيره
بعدها يجي الاكتئاب، بعدها تجي الأشياء الاجتماعية والأسرية
زي أيش؟
العلاقة مع الشريك وتربية الأبناء
العلاقة مع الوالدين، وهذه مرة موجودة بشكل كبير
فأنا أقول للآباء...
أشوف عندكم تصنيف بعد...
الآباء ارحموا أبناءكم، لا تسووا من الحبة قبة
في عندكم أشوف واحدة من التصنيفات، التعامل مع المدير
نعم
اللي حايمة كبدهم من المدير برضو يساعده؟
الرجال بالذات، العمل معنى أساسي في حياتنا
بدون العمل يمكن الكثيرين يكون يمكن ما له معنى في الحياة
معناه أساسي في حياته، ولكن العمل هذا هو ينضغط فيه
وما يقدر يجي يبين ضعفه، أحيانًا يكون المدير...
يقول لك: دائمًا أنت مهم أن تدير من تحتك موظفينك أو فريق عملك
ولكن الأهم أنك تدير مديرك، ومهم أنك تعرف تتعامل...
فهذا جزء أساسي، وهي جزء من العلاقات، أنت كيف تديره؟
لأن كثير يتأذون بشكل مرة كبير، وتجيهم اضطرابات بسبب العمل
لأن في الأخير أنت في مرحلة تكون مرتبط مع العمل
عندك قروض، قرض عقاري أو قرض...
تنجبر تقعد فيه
ما تقدر، الخروج مو بسيط، وعندك مسؤولية وأهل
وعندك تعليم لأولادك وأشياء ثانية
فبالتالي تنجبر وتضطر أنك...بعض الأشياء وأنت من الداخل
والرسول عليه الصلاة والسلام استعاذ من قهر الرجال
والمشكلة...
هي لو تأخدها «اللهم إنا نعوذ بك من الهم والحزن والعجز والكسل
وغلبة الدين وقهر الرجال»
أول اثنين الهم والحزن، أيش هم الهم والحزن؟
اليوم بلغتنا الحديثة، الاضطرابات النفسية
أعلى شيء ممكن يأثر على الإنسان الهم
أسوأ من الخوف والمرض
أنا أقول لك: الهم، الإنسان إذا كان مهموم...
الهم هو أنك تخاف من المستقبل، ومن شيء كبير
والحزن أنك تحزن على الماضي، وتندم عليه، وتنسى اللحظة
هو هنا واقعنا الحقيقي
لو بقيس على تجربتي، وتجربة الناس اللي حولي
للأسف الأصل اليوم أن مديري سيء
نعم
وإذا لقيت واحد زين تمسك فيه بالنواجد
لأن ما أنت بلاقي واحد كويس بسهولة
صحيح
للأسف غالبًا يا أن يكون...
لو بقيس على تجربتي، أنا مريت في ثلاثة أنواع من المدراء
الأكثر هم اللي «كافيك خيره وشره»
لا هو اللي بيطورك ولا هو اللي بيؤذيك، هذا تلقاه مجرد مدير
الثاني هذا الأقلية، للأسف، اللي مرة
يمكن واحد أو اثنين بس مروا علي، في كل مسيرتي العملية
وهذا اللي يطورك، اللي تدخل معه شخص، وتطلع شخص أحسن
يا سلام
الثالث هذا اللي، ما شاء الله، مبدع وهذا اللي يحط لك مجموعة أمراض
تحتاج سنتين أو ثلاثة بعدما تطلع من الوظيفة، تتطهر منها تدريجيًّا
والله خليني إذا تسمح لي احنا عندنا برنامج
بس بسوق له «لبيه للأعمال» وهو مخصص للجهات والشركات
أطلقناه هذا العام، نقدم فيه استشارات لفريق العمل بشكل مجاني
الشركة تتكفل فيها، ونقدم لهم اللي هو الدورات
يكون مجانيي للموظفين؟
مجاني للموظفين، ونقدم لهم الدورات، وورش العمل، ونقدم لهم محتوى
ونقدم لهم، عندنا تطبيق متكامل اسمه «نفس»
ومكتبة متكاملة لمحتوى التأمل
«نفس» بجيك عليه هذا بس خلنا على...
فأن هذه كل الحزمة نقدمها للموظفين بحيث أن...
وجاية برامج كثيرة للقادة والتعامل مع الموظفين
أحيانًا المدير ترى ضحية، وهذا اللي أنا شفته
هو ضحية، هو قدر الله عليه، وصار مدير
فقدّر الله عليه أنه صار مدير فهو تورّط
فصار كل قراراته، هي كل السالفة كذا اتخاذ قرار
ويضغط اللي تحته، وهو مضغوط من الإدارة
ومجلس الإدارة ضاغط الرئيس التنفيذي
فكلهم مضغوطين
حلو
فهنا الشعرة اللي أقول لك عليها، أن أنت كيف تقدر تفصل؟
شوف البرنامج المقدمينه للشركات
بعطيك اقتراح فيها عشان بس نكمل في موضوع العملاء
خلي الشركات تشوف الاستشارات جاية من أي إدارة أكثر شيء
نعم
إذا في استشارات كثيرة جاية من إدارة واحدة ففي مشكلة كبيرة
يدخل في تقييم المدير على طول
العملاء أكثرهم رجال أم نساء عندكم؟
نساء
كم النسبة؟
تقريبًا 65%
65% نساء؟
نعم
هذا يمكن، يا أن النساء مشاكلهم كثير أو الرجال يستحون؟ أحس وحدة فيهم
النساء هم أكثر طلبًا للاستشارة
وهذا أعتقد أنه عامل يجابي جدًّا كبير
لأنهم يحسون بالموضوع بشكل أكبر، ويتخدون القرار
أنا أقرأها زي كذا
أن عندهم حس عالي، وبالتالي يبادرون
أحيانًا تكون مرتبطة بالهرمونات
وأحيانًا تكون مرتبطة ببعض الأشياء، وأحيانًا أشياء وراثية
ولكن الزبدة في الموضوع أنهم يأخدون الاستشارة...
دامنا على سيرة الإحصائيات في موضوع الخصوصية
أنا أيش يضمن لي اليوم جاي أخذ استشارة عندك
بتروح تشيك علي بعد الحلقة تشوف، أيش قال مشهور؟ إيوة
أولًا الخصوصية في «لبيه»
من أكثر الأشياء اللي ساعدت الناس أنهم يجون في «لبّيه»
من أعلى...، هي شوف «لبّيه» أقول لك: حل ثلاث مشاكل أساسية
أولها الخصوصية، ثانيها الوصول
وممكن بعدين نتكلم عليه هذا مرة مهم
وبعدين (Stigma) اللي هي وصمة العار
الخصوصية ووصمة العار تقريبًا مرة مرتبطين مع بعض
أيش يضمن لي الحين؟
أول شيء الأرقام مشفرة بشكل كامل، ما نطلع عليها
إلا إذا العميل جاء قال: هذا رقم جوال كلموني
النقطة الثانية: الرسائل والاتصال كلها مشفرة
النقطة الثالثة: أنت تقدر تدخل باسم مستعر، ما نعرف مين
تدخل باسم سين، ادخل وخُد الاستشارة
هدفنا الأساسي أن نعالجك، ونساعدك في تحسين حياتك
نمط حياتك يتحسن، وتأخذ الاستشارة من واحد مختص
النقطة الأساسية، والمهم...
زي ما قلنا أيضًا من الأشياء تقدر تحذف حسابك
قبلما تشوف أنت، لا أمزح
هل في تشريع مثلًا هل فيه احد من برة يراقب وضع تشفير البيانات أو شيء؟
على أساس...
في الآن لوائح بدأت تطلع، وتحسن المنظومة بشكل كامل
وأعتقد هذا لكل القطاعات، وفي أشياء مخصصة للجانب الصحي
احنا من الأشياء اللي ممكن أقولها أن احنا حاصلين حتى على معايير عالمية
في معيار عالمي اسمه «هبة» زي «آي إس أو» وغيرها
«هبة»؟
«هبة» اللي هو تداول البيانات في المجال الطبي
و«لبيه» الحمد لله، من الناس اللي حرصنا عليه
فاحنا نحرص على هذا الشي بشكل كبير، فهذا اللي أقدر أقوله
وأتوقع برضو فيه عندكم نقطة ثانية يمكن ما غطيناها
على موضوع وصمة العار والنظره الاجتماعية
ممكن يكون في مشكلة مع العملاء من الجانب الديني، كيف يفسر؟
أشوف تصير فيها لخبطة عند الناس أحيانًا أن إذا جاءه مثلًا ضيقة صدر
يربطها مباشرة أنه التزم بصلاتك عشان تروح
يعتقد أن الجانب الروحي يقدر يعالج جانب ثاني عنده
صحيح
بينما أنت لازم تعمل بالأسباب، ديننا وصانا على هذا الشيء
فجاءك شيء عضوي أو نفسي
الجانب الروحي مهم جدًّا، ولازم تلتزم فيه دائمًا
وله دور في تحسين نفسيتك، بلا شك
صحيح، تسمح لي أشرح في هذه النقطة
أنا بعطيك إياه مثال، وبالمثال يتضح المقابل، جميل
اليوم، اترك المرضى النفسيين، خلينا نركز على الأسنان مثلًا
هل أنت لو جاء تسوس في أسنانك راح تدري عنه من البداية؟
لا، فبالتالي تطور الوعي الإنساني
وتطور عن طريق المدارس والحملات وغيرها والأدوات
فالناس ثلاثة أنواع في اللي يفرش يوميًّا
هذا أفضل شيء يفرش مرتين لثلاث مرات، ويروح للدكتور
كل ستة شهور؟
كل ست شهور، مرة أو مرتين في السنة
في الغالب هو هنا اتخذ إجراءات وقائية، حمى نفسه
في اللي ما يروح للدكتور
يفرش أوقات العزايم
أوقات العزايم وغيره، أيش راح يصير؟
أنت مضطر راح تروح
يومًا ما راح تروح للدكتور، وراح يخلع السن
وراح يأخذ معاك إجراءات مرة صعبة
راح يضطر أنه يسوي معاك إجراءات أنت مؤلمة لك ومكلفة
المرض النفسي نفس الشيء، ليش؟
المرض النفسي باختصار هو كيمياء المخ لا تعمل بشكل جيد
فالهرمونات حقت المخ تضعف، وأسبابها مرة كثيرة
لكن أهم سبب فيها اللي الناس عندهم منتشر
اللي هو الضغوطات والعامل الجيني، وبالتالي أنت مع تراكم فيه
في أشياء يمكن من الطفولة عندنا، ما ندري عنها
فاليوم الإحصائيات تقول: واحد من كل ثلاثة شخص يعاني من اضطراب نفسي
في مرحلة من حياته في السعودية، الثلث
اللي يسعون للعلاج أقل من 5% منهم
لكن الشيء الأساسي هنا عشان نفهم الموضوع
أن الموضوع ما هو متعلق بالجانب الديني
الموضوع متعلق بكيمياء الجسم، فهنا التحدي الأساسي
نرجع نفس السوسة، هل أنت شفتها؟ ما شفتها
فبالتالي الموضوع النفسي نفس الشيء
أنت لازم تأخذ إجراءات وقائية من بدري
جزء منها الجانب الروحي، لأنه مرة مهم للإنسان
كل واحد...، مثلًا أنا باسم ممكن أرتاح كثير مع قراءة القرآن
يمكن مشهور مع الصلاة، لكن لا يعني...
في كثير حتى ناس من أهل الدين يعانون
في بعضهم اليوم بدأ صار عنده الوعي موجود، يتكلم في هذا الموضوع
كلنا من أهل الدين، إن شاء الله
إن شاء الله، نتكلم وهنا النقطة الأساسية
وموضوع السكري
أنا ما ودي نتشعب
آخر مثال، مرض السكر، أنا عندي الوالد، الله يشفيه لنا ويحفظه
عنده مرض السكر من خمسة وثلاثين سنة، وثلاثة من أخواني معهم
الأطفال في العائلة، اثنين أو ثلاثة عندهم مرض السكر
فمرض السكر عندنا في العائلة
وهو جزء اللي يخليني أتبنى هذا الموضوع في مجال الصحة
وبالتحديد الصحة النفسية
وكيف انها ممكن تساعد الإنسان في تخطي حتى أمراض عضوية؟
الزبدة في الموضوع
هل قبل 100 سنة كان أحد يعرف الإنسولين؟
هل اليوم أنت تشوف الإنسولين؟ ما تشوف
هو في جسم الإنسان، أنت تأخذ إبرة
مريض السكر يأخذ إبرة كل يوم أو إبرتين
أنت تتكلم في السنة 700 إبرة وزيادة، عشان يوازن
المجال النفسي نفس الشيء
أنت ممكن تحتاج دواء أو جلسة علاج معرفي سلوكي، ويساعدها الرياضة
الرياضة تساعد البويصلات أو أن المخ يفرز
أيضًا موضوع الأكل وموضوع اللي كثير ما يدرون عنه، اللي هو أيش؟ النوم
أنت ذكرت كل الأشياء اللي نسويها غلط، نسهر، وما نأكل زين
فبالتالي
وما نسوي رياضة
عشان كذا لما يجي بعدين يقول لك: جاتني عين أو جاني شيء
فأنت لو رجعت نمط حياتك وشفت أيش صار؟
الظروف والضغوطات اللي جات عليك، والأشياء اللي أكلتك
يقول لك: والله مقهور، أنت كيف تعاملت بعدها؟
بس هنا يمكن ينقلنا لنقطة مهمة
وهي موضوع أني، أنت أول كمنصة
كيف تحسن عملية الربط بين العميل والمختص؟
أنا الحين عميل ممكن جاي، في ناس، ما شاء الله، كثير
أي شعور يحسون فيه اكتئاب
صح
بغض النظر هو قلق أو أيًّا كان أيش فيني؟ والله مكتئب
يا حبيبي أيش مكتئب؟ ما نمت زين أنت بس
فالاكتئاب مظلة كبيرة جدًّا
بينما لو تدخل في المنصة عندك في 70 تصنيف
صح
وأنت الآن كمنصة تقنية عندك دكاترة بتخصصات مختلفة
وعندك 70 مرض، الله يكفينا الشر
عندك تصنيفات كثيرة، أنا يوم دخلت ما فهمت أغلب الأشياء الموجودة
قعدت ساعة أدور
كيف تقدر تحسن بين جودة الربط بين العميل وأيش فيه
وبين المختص اللي يقدر يساعده؟
ما يصير يدخل عند واحد، ويقول: لا أنت ما تصلح لي؟
صحيح، هو تحدي الربط مع المختص المناسب
حتى لو أنك تعرف أنت، أيش عندك؟
أحيانًا ما تروح للمختص اللي مرة فاهم الحالة بشكل جيد
هذه تصير، احنا، الحمد لله، لأن لما قلت لك: الوصول
جزء من أهم قيم «لبّيه» وأهم الحلول اللي وفرها
أن أنت تقدر توصل لي من أي مكان
اليوم عندنا السعودية فيها 10 مليون إنسان
خارج المدن الكبيرة ما عندهم وصول لخدمات الصحة النفسية
اللي زي «لبّيه»
«لبّيه» قدر يوصل لك اليوم في هذه اللحظة
أنت تقدر تستفيد من الخدمة
فهنا نجي للتحدي لما تدخل في التطبيق
فعملنا أكثر من حل، أول شيء حطينا مقاييس نفسية
والمقاييس هذه تعطيك مؤشر، كيف وضعك، ممتاز؟
وبعدين نعطيك توصيات، مَن أحسن الناس في هذا المجال؟
اقتراحات
هذه النقطة الأولى، النقطة الثانية: عملنا زي تقييم أو استبيان
الاستبيان هذا يبين لك أنت تعاني كذا من متى وليش؟
فبالتالي يبين لك مين الموضوع، ويقدر يساعدك
أحيانًا بعض الناس مهم أن الآن
عامل الوقت هو العامل الحاسم عنده في الموضوع، أن الآن أنا أحتاج أحد
فنبين لهم مين الدكاترة المتاحين الآن أو عندنا استشارة فورية
أيش الحالات اللي تحتاج، الحين أحتاج أحد أكلمه؟
في حالات انتحار مثلًا أو واحد يبغى ينتحر؟
في الحالات الخطرة إيوة
حسنًا، شلوة تتعاملون معه؟
أقدر الحين بسرعة أنا خلاص بذبح نفسي، الله يكفينا الشر
أبغى أكلم دكتور الآن؟ هل هذا شيء تدعمونه؟
أخوي مشهور أنت تكلمت في موضوع مرة حساس
وموضوع بالنسبة لي أنا شخصيًّا يضايقني كثير حقيقةً
موضوع الحالات الخطرة هو موجود في المجتمع
ما نقدر، احنا اليوم، الحمد لله، مع رؤية 2030
واحد من أهم المبادئ الأساسية فيها والركائز، جودة الحياة ومجتمع حيوي
مجتمع حيوي بدون صحة نفسية صعب، أساسها الصحة النفسية
أيضًا النقطة الثانية: أن من المميزات أنك أنت تواجه المشاكل والتحديات
هو تحدي موجود عندنا
تحدي موجود الحالات الخطرة، فيجيون يتواصلوا معنا، ويطلبون...
احنا عملنا بروتوكول خاص للحالات الخطرة والتعامل معها
دربنا عليها المختصين، وفي أسئلة، لما يجي هو يعبّي الاستبيان اللي تكلمت لك عنه
يبين، هل أنت خططت مثلًا للانتحار أو عندك رغبّة؟
فبالتالي يصير في مشغل في الموضوع هذا
عندنا المختصين دربناهم على التعامل مع الحالات
في زي آليات معينة أنك أنت تستخدمها
بعضهم يبقى مع الحالة ساعتين أو ثلاث ساعات
معاه على التليفون، وأحيانًا يطلب منه رقم أحد قريب منه
تتعاونون مع جهات في الموضوع هذا وللا لا؟
تعاون بسيط، لأن اليوم أحد الأشياء اللي نتمنى أن تكون موجودة
يكون عندنا مبادرة وطنية متكاملة للتعاون مع الحالات الخطرة
سواءً في «لبّيه» أو خارجه
وتكلمنا مؤخرًا مع المركز الوطني
والآن شغالين معهم على الدراسة في هذا الموضوع
بحيث أننا نطلع ببروتوكول بحلول وبمادرات لتحل هذا التحدي
إن شاء الله، لو أن فقط في السنة كلها شخص واحد
لكن يستحق الرعاية والاهتمام
عدد كبير اللي...؟
ما هو كبير مرة بس ما هو قليل، وسط
آلاف؟
آلاف إيوة، من أول ما بدأنا «لبيه»
في اتجاه أشوفه عالمي كبير في الأعمال التجارية عمومًا
اللي هو في موضوع التأمل، والتطبيقات ناجحة بشكل كبير فيه
صحيح
اللي هو «كالم» و«هيد سبيس»
وما شاء الله، يرعون برامج بودكاست كثيرة
بس أشوف مثلًا «كالم» و«هيد سبيس» مكسرين الدنيا
ما شاء الله، أداؤهم جدًّا ممتاز، سعوديين كثير مشتركين فيهم
نعم
فلو تعطينا بس شرح بسيط عن هذا النوع من التطبيقات
وبرضو تكلمنا عن استحواذكم على تطبيق «نفس»
أبشر، والله صحيح هي اتجاه عالمي
والسبب الأساسي اللي تكلمنا عليه
الضغوطات اللي اليوم، الحياة المعاصرة مختلفة عن الحياة السابقة
الإنسان اليوم يميل للعزلة، ولأنه يشتغل كثير
هذه الأشياء تساعده، طرق حديثة للعلاج
مثلًا تطبيق «كالم» اليوم تقييمه أكثر من 2 مليار
آخر جولة سوّاها بـ 200 مليون دولار
هذا يبين لك اتجاه، وفي استثمارات كبيرة في هذا المجال
«هيد سبيس» اللي أنت تكلمت عنه
دُمج مع تطبيق ثاني اسمه «جينجر» وهو مختص في العلاج
«جينجر» علاج و«هيد سبيس» تأمل
دُمجوا مع بعض، تقيمهم أكثر من 4 مليار دولار
4 مليار؟
4 مليار دولار نعم
ملايين الملايين عندهم مستخدمين
وفي جزء منها علمية اللي يسمونها (Mindfulness) «تركيز كامل للذهن»
ترجمها هذه
وهي طرق علمية، وهي موجة جديدة أصلًا من العلاج
بالتالي هي زبدتها أنك تعيش اللحظة
أنا في ثقافتنا أسميها الخشوع
الخشوع مرتبط بالدين
بالدين، بس الخشوع تقدر تخشع في اللحظة
وتنبسط بكوب القهوة اللي قدامك
فهذه هي فكرتها، أنك أنت تعيش اللحظة، وتنعزل عن اللي حولك
بحيث أنك أنت ترتاح
النقطة الثانية في الموضوع هي كلها مرتبطة بالمخ
أنت ليش تروح النادي؟
الصحة
الصحة وتقلل الوزن، وتبني عضلات صح وللا لا؟
صح
متى آخر تمرين سويته لمخك؟
إي، أنا شوف...
فهمت النقطة؟
اشتركت في «كالم» على فكرة، وجربت تمارينهم
هم عندهم اشتراك شهري بعدين تقدر تأخذ تمارينهم
ما ضبطت معي مدري ليش؟
هي مو لكل الناس صح، ومو قريبة لثقافتنا
لأن هي فكرتها على الأقل من التسجيلات اللي سمعتها
صح
تحط سماعات بعدين يقول لك: غمض عيونك، وخُذ نفس كبير
تخيل الهواء يمشي
أنا ما أدري هل الفكرة أن على أساس توقف تفكير وتركز في اللحظة وللا لا؟
هي كذا فكرتها؟
وغمض وما أدري أيش تخيل
بعدين بعد خمس دقائق مثلًا يقول: افتح الحين
فعيت تضبط معي صراحةً، لكنه اتجاه يدخل فلوس كثير
اتجاه كبير ومو بسيط، وأعتقد أنه مرة مهم
لأنه يتعلق بجانب الوقاية، اللي تكلمنا عليه في البداية
لأن الوقاية مرة مهمة
الوقاية في الجانب النفسي متعلقة بهذه الأشياء
لأن مهم أن تعرف نفسك وذاتك
وأيش اللي يضايقك وأيش اللي لا؟
وكيف تتعامل إذا جاءت لحظة معينة؟
مستحيل يكون هناك أطباء لكل الناس صح وللا لا؟
في الأخير هذا تحدي، مستحيل أن...
أصلًا عددهم مرة قليل في السعودية مقارنة بـ...
احنا في السعودية لكل 100 ألف سعودي 2.5 طبيب نفسي؟
فاحنا مرة بعيدين عن...فصعب
حتى في العالم كله في قلة في عدد المختصين
لذلك هذه الممارسات مرة مهمة
هي نقطة الكلام فيها أنها...
كم المفروض يكون في طبيب لكل 100 ألف؟
زي الدول الاسكندنافية لأن مرة ممتازين، تقريبًا عشرين
حسنًا
هم مرة متقدمين في هذا المجال
فالنقطة الأساسية هنا...
تركز على جانب الوقاية، بحيث يقل الطلب على...
بالضبط، جانب الاسترخاء، وأنك تعيش اللحظة
وهي كلها تمارين للدماغ
في الأخير أن مخ الإنسان يحتاج أنك تفضيه من الضغوطات اللي تدخل له
بس الحين «نفس» زي «كالم» و«هيد سبيس»
بالضبط، احنا جاءت الفكرة هنا
شركة سعودية هي؟
شركة إماراتية، واحنا استحوذنا عليها
السبب الأساسي كالتالي، اليوم أنت لما تأخذ القطاع فيه أربع مراحل
المرحلة الأولى: التوعية، أن الناس تصير عندها توعية
المرحلة الثانية: اللي هي الوقاية
وهي تدخل فيها المقاييس النفسية والتأمل وغيره
بعدين تدخل مرحلة العلاج
العلاج جزء منه العلاج مثلًا عبر الإنترنت في «لبيه»
أو حضوري في العيادات
بعدين تجي المرحلة الأخيرة ما بعد العلاج
وهذه دائمًا في الحالات الصعبة مثل حالات الإدمان والمصحات وغيرها، هذا باختصار
واحنا جينا في «لبيه» نقدم العلاج، وعندنا المساعدة
وعندنا الوعي الحملات اللي عملناها
حملات «لبيه» وصلت إلى أكثر من 100 مليون إنسان
هدفنا الأساسي والكبير أن نساعد 100 مليون
اليوم احنا وصلنا لـ2 مليون، إن شاء الله...
بجيك على الموضوع...
بقول لك هنا الزبدة: أن استحوذنا على نفس
عشان نكمل الرحلة العلاجية للعيمل
نموذج عملهم قبلما تستحوذون عليهم، كان اشتراك؟
اشتراك، نعم
اشتراك سنة
كان في إقبال على الخدمة؟
عندهم مليون تحميل
بس كاشتراكات؟
لا، مو كثير
وأنت تبغى تدمجها مع «لبّيه»؟
نعم، بحيث أن الرحلة تكون متكاملة للعميل
ما بين علاج وما بين تأمل وتوعية، ومحتوى يساعد على النوم
لأن تكلمنا عليه أنه من أهم الأشياء
والله كثير طلع يسمعون البودكاست عشان ينامون
إي، تطبيق «كالم» هذا لو تدخل عليه
يقول لك: تطبيق يساعد على النوم، كذا مكتوب
أنا متأكد في واحد الآن منسدح، وقاعد يسمع كلامنا
نعم
والحين فتح عيونه فجأة
بالضبط
واحنا ننصحهم أنهم يستخدمونها
مثلًا لو تدخل على اليوتيوب، شوف القصص
وبعضهم هو قناته أنه يسرد قصص، والناس كلها تسمعها وقت النوم
القصص تساعد على الاسترخاء، وضغطك يقل
وتساعدك أنك تدخل في النوم بسلاسة
أتمنى اللي حاط رأسه على المخدة الحين يقدر الشيء هذا
كتسويق، شلون تروج الخدمة؟
خدمة «نفس»؟
لا «لبيه»
هل تعاني من ضغوط؟
لا، نقول له: في مقياس تعال، وتعرف على نفسك
الناس تحب تعرف نفسها
فالمقاييس هذه حلوة، وساعدوه
مقاييسة أيش؟
المقاييس النفسية اللي عندنا
«لبيه» فيه سبعة مقاييس نفسية
بالتالي أنا أنصح أي أحد يأخذها، بعدين تشوف وضعك
المقاييس هذه علمية ومعتمدة
ومن الأشياء اللي نسويها، ونحرص عليها نعمل محاضرات توعوية
أنا أقول لك: المجال هذا إذا ما وعيت فيه من الصعب أنك تأخذ خطوة
أنتم قد سويتوا بودكاست الظاهر قبل صح؟
نعم، في بودكاست لـ«لبيه»
مين تقابلوا فيه؟
نقابل فيه المختصين والمستشارين نعم، ونرعى...
وسويته برضو عشان تثقفون؟
كله توعية، احنا اليوم عندنا مثلًا في اليوتيوب حلقة كل أسبوع
موقع «لبيه» نشرنا فيه أكثر من 500 مقال
شهريًّا مئات الآلاف من الناس تدخل عشان تتوعى في المجال
أتكلم أن نقطة أساسية في هذا المجال أن الناس يصير عندها الوعي الكافي
وأنا لو تقول لي: باسم أيش اللي تطمح له؟
أطمح أن يصير وعي الناس في المجال النفسي زي وعيهم باهتمامهم بأسنانهم
حلو، فأساليب التسويق كلها مركزة على الاختبارات؟
لا، محتوى وقراءة، تقرأ مقالات وفيديوهات وبودكاست ومقاييس
ومحتوى على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي، ومحتوى بلغة الناس
والتحديات اللي تواجههم بشكل مباشر، كيف تتعامل معها؟
أحيانًا يكون محتوى تفاعلي
عندنا مثلًا جلسات الدعم داخل التطبيق
تدخل مع ناس يمرون بنفس الوضع اللي أنت فيه
وتتبادلون التجارب وغيرها من الأشياء
فهذه كلها جزء أساسي من التسوق
التحديات اللي تواجهونها أول شيء
الطلب هل هو موسمي على التطبيق ولا ما يتأثر؟
لا، ما يتأثر
مكمل، المشاكل موجودة طول السنة
الله المستعان
الشيء الثاني أتوقع فيه دائمًا في القطاع الصحي
في الشركات الناشئة تواجه...
ما أبي أقول تهديد بس أن خطر مستمر أو تهديد إذا نسميه
أن ممكن مشرع وزارة الصحة يبدأ يقدم الخدمة بشكل مجاني
صحيح
هذه جهود يشكرون عليها أنهم يقدمون الخدمات هذه
شفنا شركات ثانية ناشئة في الطب الاتصالي بدأت وزارة الصحة تقدم نفس الخدمة
بشكل مجاني، فهل هذا شيء...؟
والله يا طويل العمر، بالعكس هو يكبر السوق، هذا اللي خدمنا
في البداية كنت متضايق شخصيًّا
قدموها الآن؟
إي يقدموها، بس يقدمون استشارات بكل شيء، هو جزء...
اليوم رؤية 2030 والتحول اللي صاير في المجال الطبي
هو يهدف إلى أن التحول إلى الوقاية، المستشفيات والأسرة ما تشيلها الناس
هو تقليل للتكلفة بعد
تقليل للتكلفة، فبالتالي الطب الاتصالي مهم
لكن الزبدة وين؟
والوزارة ما راح تنتظر إلى أن تطلع شركات
هي أكثر من نقطة، أول شيء: نوعية العلاج النفسي مختلفة
هي ليست استشارة وحدة، هي رحلة
فبالتالي في العلاج عبر الإنترنت حتى مع الوزارة وغيره
أنا ما راح أجي عشان مرة وحدة
أنا جاي عشان أكثر من جلسة، إلى أن أحل التحدي والمشكلة التي أنا واقع فيها
هذا «لبيه» يوفره
الشيء الثاني: أن الناس في طبيعتهم، الإنسان يزهد في كل شيء مجاني
رضيت أم أبيت يزهد في المجاني
يدفع فلوس عشان يهتم في الموضوع
وفي تعاون بينكم وبين الوزارة؟
نعم، بعض المبادرات البسيطة
لكن أنا لو تقول لي: أيش اللي أتمناه؟
التوعية، هذا دور أساسي للوزارة، ولـ«لبيه» وللمجتمع
مهم أن الجميع يكون عنده وعي
حاطينكم تحت أي تشريع؟
احنا بالطب الاتصالي وفي...نعتبر كأننا مستشفى بس رقمي
حلو، كم عميل وصلتوا اليوم؟
مسجلين 2 مليون مستخدم
2 مليون؟
مستخدم نعم
الفعّالين؟
الفعالين أكثر من 500 ألف إذا أنت تقول: بس استشارات
نقدر نتكلم عن إيرادات السنة الماضية، كم؟
والله الحمد لله، ممتازة
بس
بس ما احنا شبكة ربحانة عشان ما...
بس تقدر تعطي تقدير كذا؟
لا والله
ما تقدر تشاركها
اعذرني من هذه الإجابة
لحساسية الموضوع ما أبغى، أنا أتفاهم ممكن تكون انعكاسات عليكم
وين متوجهين في «لبيه»؟
«لبيه» وين متوجه؟ سؤال مرة مهم
أنا خليني زي ما قلت لك: المجال جزء من أن تعرف التوجه تفهم المجال
زي ما قلت لك: احنا نحاول نبني منظومة متكاملة عبر الإنترنت رقمية
في مجال الصحة النفسية
بحيث أن العميل يقدر يستفيد من الخدمة بشكل متكامل
قاعدين نبني برامج علاجية، والبرامج هذه مرة مهمة
أنها تسهل لك وضوح الهدف، ونضع جودة معينة
أيضًا تسهل لك الرحلة بشكل كامل
من الأشياء اللي شغالين عليها بشكل كبير التكامل
التكامل مع مثلًا صيدليات، واحدة من أكبر السجليات السعودية
بحيث أن حتى صرف الدواء يكون مرة سهل وبسيط
من الأشياء المهمة بالنسبة لنا استخدام التقنيات المتقدمة
أعتقد اليوم المستقبل بالتقنيات المتقدمة، أتكلم عن الذكاء الاصطناعي
يعالجني الذكاء الاصطناعي؟
نعم، «لبيه» الآن شغالة على نموذج مو يعالجك
لكن في أشياء ممكن تتأتمت بشكل كبير أهمها التوعية
أنا باختصار أبغى أعرف بسرعة
ممكن الذكاء الاصطناعي هذا مرة شيء بسيط
واحنا شغالين عليه، وممكن يطلع قبل نهاية السنة، بإذن الله
أيضًا من الأشياء المهمة...
ما تحسه يتعارض مع موضوع تشفير البيانات؟
لا أتكلم التوعية أن أنت زي دردشة يجاوبك على...
ما يستفيد من بيانات الاستشارات؟
لا، ما له دخل أو ممكن يرشح لك الناس الأفضل في التحدي اللي أنت تواجهه
كمان من الأشياء اللي احنا مركزين عليها بشكل كبير
أن ندمج التأمل بشكل كبير مع العلاج، لأن هذا الجزء أساسي
كذلك من ناحية المختصين تطويره وتأهيله بشكل أكبر
لأن نحتاج كثير مختصين، اليوم احنا عندنا العدد أقل من اللازم
وأعتقد أن فيه فرصة مرة كبيرة في المجال
مشهور المجال حجمه عالميًّا 400 مليار دولار
2030 أتوقع أن 550
ما في أحد ثاني من المجال نفسكم وللا؟
للأسف، اليوم السوق في السعودية....
أنتم الشركة الوحيدة اللي شغالين فيه؟
لا، في موجود، بس أن ما زلنا كلنا ما أعتقد أن بالحجم الكبير
لكن عالميًّا هو اتجاه عالمي
بس مو من المنافسين، ما قد سمعت إلا...
في منافسين، بس أن ما هم في الصورة
يمكن «لبيه» أكثر منهم معرفة
لكن في أكثر من منافس محليًّا وفي عربيًّا كمان
لكن أنا أتكلم الاستثمارات حجمها مرة ضعيف، هذا جزء من التحدي في السوق
أنت تتكلم على مجال ينمو سنويًّا أكثر من 5%
هذا بس الصحة العقلية الرقمية
5% على حجم السوق اللي ذكرته؟
إي، أنت تتكلم عن الصحة العقلية الرقمية اليوم حجمه بالمليارات
الصحة الرقمية بشكل كامل 400 مليار
في السعودية هنا حجم السوق أكثر من 70 مليار دولار كصحة
ليش تتوقع أنهم ما يبغون يستثمرون فيه؟
ما يفهمونه بشكل كبير، أحيانًا ممكن يخشون أن السوق مو كبير
مو بحجم كافي
برضو كونه في القطاع الصحي يخوف شوي
نعم، القطاع الصحي شوي حساس، والتشريعات فيه حساسة برضو
ولكن الفرصة موجودة، سلوك الناس
أنت لا تنظر اللي يستثمر لا ينظر للواقع الحالي، تنظر المستقبل
المستقبل مختلف تمامًا
احنا فيه أشياء اليوم نستخدمها لو جيتك قبل خمسة سنوات
تقول لي: كيف هذا مو طبيعي، قبل عشر سنوات
اليوم هي جزء أساسي من حياتك
وأنا أتكلم اليوم الصحة النفسية، صح أنها بعضهم يقول لك: اتجاه
لا ما هو اتجاه، هو وعي أساسي، حظر ليبقى
كان ما هو واضح للناس قبل كذا، اليوم صار يوضح
اليوم، الحمد لله، الوعي صار مرة كبير
بس معلش سؤال على موضوع الاستثمار، ما قفلتوا أي جولة استثمارية؟
قفلنا جولتين، وهذه من الأشياء اللي...
إيوة، هذا لاقي فلوس
بس آخر جولة كانت «ما قبل المرحلة ألف»
النقطة الأساسية، الحمد لله «لبيه» تأخرت كثير
أول جولة أخذناها عام 2021
المستثمرين دخلوا معنا عام 2021 خلال سنة أكثر من عشرة أضعاف
عشرة أضعاف
إي أقل شيء عشرة أضعاف، على طول الجولة اللي بعدها
أقصدك أن في نمو كبير
أتكلم لك في 2020 احنا سوينا مليون دقيقة
اليوم احنا مسوين 50 مليون دقيقة، تخيل
خلال السنتين ونص هذا النمو الكبير في تقديم الخدمة، والوصول للناس
الناس تحتاج دعم، ظروف الحياة مختلفة، والتحديات موجودة
وأحيانًا التحديات ما هو أنت تبغى، هي تجيك وتفرض عليك
تخرج ويمكن يصير لك، سبحان الله، أي إنسان يصير له حادث
ولا يفقد أحد قريب
كيف تتعامل معه؟ مو كل الناس عندهم القدرة
في ناس، سبحان الله، ربي وهبهم هذه الهبة
في التعامل مع الصدمات والضغوطات بشكل جيد
لكن في ناس كثير ما يقدرون
فبالتالي يروح لمنحنى..
أنت لو جيته في المرحلة الصح ومن بدري، وحليت المشكلة
والله أن ما يدخل في هذه التحديات
خلني أقول لك قصة عبدالعزيز، أحد عملائنا
مين عبدالعزيز؟
واحد من اوائل العملاء في «لبيه»
وقتها كان عندنا مركز اتصال، ويتصل علينا
فيتصل أبغى أكلم المدير
يكلمه المشرف، يقول له: أنت المدير؟ قال: لا، قال: ما أبغاك
كلمه مدير العمليّات، قال: لا جيب مديرك
المهم أن الرجال صامل
في اليوم يدق مرة أو مرتين لمدة شهر
الموضوع...، الشباب قالوا: يمكن أيش...
والمشكلة وين؟ أنت أيش موضوعك أو مشكلتك أيش بالضبط؟ قُلها لي
ما يقولها
يبغى يوصل لك
إيوة، آخر شيء قالوا لي: الموضوع...
عبدالعزيز يبيك
عزيزي يبغاك يا بش مهندس، شوف لنا حل مع الرجال هذا
وسبحان الله، قلت: خلاص أنا أكلمه، واتصل، وأنا رديت
مرحبًا وأهلًا وسهلًا، قال: مين معي؟ قلت: معاك باسم البلادي
كيف حالك؟
لا، قال: أنت المدير؟ قلت له: إيوة انا المدير
قال: احلف
إيوة
قلت: والله، قال: من جدك أنت المدير؟
خلاص ابحث الحين عبر الإنترنت واكتب وشوف
شاف وأخد دقيقة على الجوال كذا
ورجع، قال: إي والله صح، أنت باسم البلادي؟
قلت: إي أنا باسم البلادي
قلت له: أنا بفهم بس أخوي أنت في أحد زعلك من عندنا؟
أو صارت لك مشكلة في التطبيق، في دكتور أو مختص؟
الظاهر في مشكلة، أول شيء أنا أعتذر لك مقدمًا
قبل لا تتكلم، وتشرح لي المشكلة، وأبشر بالعوض
قال: لا ما أحد زعلني، قلت: طيب
قال: يا البلادي كا قال لي، لو أنك قدامي أبوسك على رأسك
أنا كذا وقفت، قلت: تسمح لي بس بفهم الموضوع
الله يجزاك الخير، وما سوينا إلا الواجب، ما سويت شيء أنا
بس بفهم أيش الموضوع؟
قال: أنت ما تدري أيش الموضوع؟ قلت: لا والله
قال: أنا أكثر من خمس سنوات أعاني
هو ساكن في شمال السعودية، كنت أسافر ست ساعات عشان أتعالج
وتكاليف وما كان...أنا بالطريقة الممتازة
الزبدة، قلت: كنت تروح للرياض يعني؟
قال: لا، كنت أروح عمّان في الأردن
قلت: كيف، كنت تروح دولة ثانية؟
قال: إي، أروح لكن الحمد لله، الآن ستة شهور في «لبيه»
الوضع بدأ يتحسن، وجلس يشكر، ويعطيه العافية
قفل الاتصال، وأنا بكيت، تقول لي: ليش؟
هنا الأثر، اللي أنت أحيانًا تسوي شيء تحسن من حياة الناس
وكثير القصص، الحمد لله، مو بس عبدالعزيز
أحيانًا والله أشياء بسيطة، وأحيانًا أشياء مرة كبيرة
وأحيانًا أشياء أسرية، وأحيانًا تحافظ على أسرة
تبني حياة إنسان أو تساعده يتطور مهنيًّا
ونروح والله دائمًا في التجمعات أو غيره لما يدرون
يجي يقول لك: أنا والله صار لي كذا
وكنت ممكن من مشاكل الأسرة بنفصل
لكن، الحمد لله، الدكتور الفلاني عندكم ما قصر معاي، وأنتم ساعدتوني
فأعتقد أن واحد وصل لقناعة من السهل أنك تسوي عمل تجاري
وسهل أنك تطلع فلوس، لكن صعب أنك تسوي عمل تجاري يغير حياة الناس
هنا التحدي الكبير
جميل
هذه من القصص اللي أثرت فيني، وفي أكثر من شيء
الله يعطيك العافية أخوي باسم، أثريتنا اليوم وأسعدتنا
أنا كنت متهم جدًّا في موضوع الطب النفسي
وتقديمه من خلال عمل تجاري عبر الإنترنت
فألف شكر لك على مشاركتك التفاصيل اليوم
الله يعطيك العافية أخوي مشهور
شاكر لك ولسوالف بزنس ولثمانية
ويعطيكم العافية، وأتمنى أني قدمت لهم معلومة مفيدة
الله يعطيك العافية ما قصرت
الله يسعدك، شكرًا
شكرًا لكم ولعبد الملك آل سعيد في إنتاج المحتوى
في التحرير: مرام ضبيبان
في إدارة التصوير: ياسر بن غانم
في الإضاءة: عبدالمجد عمر
في الهندسة الصوتية: يوسف إبراهيم
في الإخراج الإبداعي: وهّاب موسى
في الإخراج الفني: مجد الملي، ومساعده: وسيم معين
وفي الإنتاج التنفيذي: غيداء التميمي
هذا بودكاس سوالف بزنس، أحد منتجات شركة ثمانية للنشر والتوزيع